I'm just the country boy at heart, no frills, no bravado. I'm from Birmingham, God damn. Don't ask me shit about avocados. Look a man in his eyes when you shake his hand. That's all that I know. I'm irreverent. And my daddy is still a reverend on the Bible. Every day above grounds, brindle.
我内心深处只是个乡下男孩，没有虚饰，没有狂妄。我来自伯明翰，该死。别问我关于牛油果的破事。握手时要直视对方的眼睛。这就是我所知道的一切。我玩世不恭。我爸爸至今仍是位虔诚的牧师。只要还活在世上，就得脚踏实地。
All right, I'm here with Pinkbeard. Welcome to the show. And we go ahead and shred all these questions that I had written about avocados. and hopefully we could find something else to talk about. Hopefully it does. Yeah. What I really appreciate you coming on, Discover Hill Grove, the Tapreet Therapy Collective Podcasts.
好了，我和Pinkbeard在一起。欢迎来到节目。我们这就把那些我写好的关于牛油果的问题统统撕掉，希望我们能找到其他话题聊聊。希望如此。是的。我真的很感谢你能来参加《发现希尔格罗夫》（Discover Hill Grove），也就是Taproot治疗集体播客。
We're just, you know, a little local therapy, you know, firm trying to have some good conversations and find out about, like, the psychology and really like the, not just the psychology in a corny way, but like the psychological impulse of the artist, like the good and bad things that go along with it, help people try and redirect their energy to make sense. of a crazy world or change a crazy world just a little bit, plenty of craziness right now. Absolutely.
我们只是，你知道，一个当地的小型治疗机构，试图进行一些有意义的对话，去探究心理学，而且不仅仅是以那种陈词滥调的方式，而是去探究艺术家的心理冲动，比如伴随其中的好与坏，帮助人们尝试重新引导他们的能量，去理解这个疯狂的世界，或者稍微改变一下这个疯狂的世界，现在疯狂的事情太多了。绝对是这样。
You've got a new one climbing top of the pops. Like every time I check that video, it's like another five million, you know, on there. I need damn, man. Yeah. Yeah.
你有一首新歌正在冲上流行榜榜首。每次我查看那个视频，它又多了五百万次播放，你知道的。我心想，该死，伙计。是的。是的。
So congratulations. And for people who aren't familiar, Pinkfeard's done a couple things. I mean, he's done some, like, really good music. And then also just,
所以恭喜你。对于那些不熟悉的人，Pinkbeard做过几件事。我是说，他做了一些非常棒的音乐。然后还有，
I was always a huge fan of your marketing. Like the, I love the, I'm not going to fight for you. I'm going to fight for you. mayor. So please vote for me and I'll come to your house and kick your ass. I was like, I was hoping that would turn into like one of those like real LA style celebrity, you know, like Tim Heidegger style like campaigns. So you could actually vote for the person and then
我一直是你营销方式的忠实粉丝。比如，我喜欢那个“我不会为你而战。我会为你而战。市长。所以请投票给我，我会去你家踢你的屁股。”我当时心想，我希望这能变成那种真正的洛杉矶风格的名人竞选，你知道，像蒂姆·海德克（Tim Heidegger）风格的竞选。这样你真的可以投票给那个人，然后
they start winning. Yeah. Incredible, man. Yeah. I just, I want to see like the Supreme Court case. Are you like, I told you what's going to have. Told you if I want. I was going to vote. Did you vote or not? Yeah, you asked for it. Your name is on the voter roll. This matches. that was fantastic. Well, see, you've got an interesting story, and I want to get to your contemporary stuff,
他们就开始赢了。是的，太不可思议了，伙计。是的。我只是想看到那种最高法院的案件。你就像，“我告诉过你会发生什么。我告诉过你如果我赢了。我会去投票。你投票了吗？没有？是的，你自找的。你的名字在选民名单上。这匹配上了。”那太精彩了。好吧，你看，你有一个有趣的故事，我想聊聊你当代的创作，
but could you go through what it's like, you know, because I grew up in Birmingham, too. I've been here my whole life, lived in Florence, Alabama for a little bit, went to school at Swanee, but other than that, this is where I'm from. And it's an interesting area. Like, I was in New York recently to demo,
但你能讲讲那是什么感觉吗，因为我也在伯明翰长大。我这辈子一直住在这里，在阿拉巴马州的弗洛伦斯住过一小会儿，在斯瓦尼上过学，但除此之外，这就是我的家乡。这是一个有趣的地区。比如，我最近在纽约做演示，
like this new thing that we were doing a Taproot, and everybody's like, you know, like they all had fun, and I was like, yeah, I like talking to people, meag people. But then they were all kind of privately would come up and be like, are you really from Alabama? What's Alabama like? Like, I don't think of people like being from Alabama, you know?
就是我们在Taproot做的那件新事，每个人都觉得，你知道，他们都玩得很开心，我就说，是的，我喜欢和人交谈，认识人。但后来他们私下里都会过来问，你真的是来自阿拉巴马吗？阿拉巴马是什么样的？我没法想象人们来自阿拉巴马，你知道吗？
And I thought, I love that. My wife was like really uncomfortable. She was like, oh. Some of the times I'm embarrassed and was like, no, dude, I love it. I go into a room, rizzing everybody out. And then me, I'm like, I'm from Alabama. I'm from Alabama. Yeah.
我觉得这很有趣。我妻子当时真的很不自在，她说，哦。有时候我会感到尴尬，但我说，不，伙计，我喜欢这样。我走进一个房间，用魅力征服所有人。然后我，我就说，我来自阿拉巴马。我来自阿拉巴马。是的。
Like, yeah. I don't know. What's your experience? Like, what do you associate with a place or, you know, anything that kind of speaks to you or informs your work? Because you're definitely in communication with it a lot in a way that's empowering and unashamed and hopeful. Oh, man, you know, like being from Birmingham, I mean, from Alabama in general, but, you know, Birmingham specifically, you know, it's like the first lens to my whole worldview, you know? So, like, um.
就像，是的。我不知道。你的经历是什么样的？你把什么与这个地方联系在一起，或者，你知道，有什么东西触动了你或影响了你的工作？因为你确实以一种赋权、毫不羞愧且充满希望的方式与它进行了很多交流。哦，伙计，你知道，来自伯明翰，我是说，来自阿拉巴马，但你知道，特别是伯明翰，你知道，它就像我整个世界观的第一个镜头，你知道吗？所以，嗯。
Can't get away from that one. Yeah, you just can't get away. Yeah, it stays with you. Even if you rejected and rebel against it and say, I'm going to do this whole new thing and move to L.A. or New York, like, it's like, you could still kind of tell the person's rebelling against it. instead of owning it. Yeah, man. And I've always just wanted to own it. I moved to LA just because my career kind of took me that,
逃不开那个。是的，你就是逃不开。是的，它会伴随着你。即使你拒绝它、反抗它，说我要做这件全新的事情，搬到洛杉矶或纽约，就像，你仍然能看出那个人是在反抗它，而不是拥抱它。是的，伙计。我一直只想拥抱它。我搬到洛杉矶只是因为我的职业生涯把我带到了那里，
but, you know, everywhere I go, I tell people I'm, you know, I'm really proud to be from Birmingham. Because Birmingham has been really good to me. You know, I had, like, great teachers in my school system and, you know, great support system and great friends. And so, like, it's always been very much home to me. And so I try to carry it as a badge of honor in a lot of ways, specifically because when you walk into a place,
但是，你知道，无论我走到哪里，我都告诉人们，你知道，我真的很自豪能来自伯明翰。因为伯明翰对我真的很好。你知道，我的学校系统里有很棒的老师，你知道，很棒的支持系统和很棒的朋友。所以，它对我来说一直是非常像家的地方。所以我试着在很多方面把它当作一种荣誉勋章，特别是因为当你走进一个地方时，
people might have a conception about it. You know, they might have some kind of, you know, all y'all wear shoes? Yeah. Running water? Yeah, I got that too. You know, so I wear it like a badger honor, man. Burnham has been really good to me.
人们可能对它有某种成见。你知道，他们可能会有某种，你知道，“你们都穿鞋吗？”“有自来水吗？”“是的，我也有那个。”你知道，所以我把它当作荣誉勋章，伙计。伯明翰对我真的很好。
You know, every city's got his problems, but, you know, the devil that you know, you know. Yeah, and it is almost a language. You know, you can't get away from it. There's good and bad things, you know, about, about the, I think, the mythology, so we have it. But, I mean, I always enjoyed kind of about the South that it brought the worst stuff to the surface because people felt comfortable. I mean, sometimes, like, you know, I travel, get other places.
你知道，每个城市都有它的问题，但，你知道，你了解的那个恶魔，你知道的。是的，这几乎是一种语言。你知道，你逃不开它。关于这种神话，有好有坏，你知道。但是，我是说，我一直很喜欢南方的一点是，它把最糟糕的东西带到了表面，因为人们感到自在。我是说，有时候，就像，你知道，我旅行，去其他地方。
And it's like a lot of the people that I went to school with that, you know, we're for the life of a better word from the north or something. It was like, you know, things would still come out that were kind of bad, but they had this way of like making it fly to whatever. And there's something about Alabama where people just feel comfortable telling you what they believe, which a lot of them I don't like or agree with. But I'm glad you're telling me that's in there, man. because you're not making it complicated. Yeah, and that I think makes for kind of a different kind of discourse. It's like a weird culture where things are on the surface, even when they're not great. Do you just play with any of that in your music or like you kind of use that in the way that you see?
就像很多和我一起上学的人，你知道，用更好的词来说，来自北方什么的。就像，你知道，事情仍然会暴露出来，有些是相当糟糕的，但他们有一种方式让它显得……无论如何。阿拉巴马州有些地方，人们只是觉得可以自在地说出他们的信仰，其中很多我不喜欢或不同意。但我很高兴你告诉我那里面有什么，伙计。因为你没有把它复杂化。是的，我认为这造就了一种不同的话语。这是一种奇怪的文化，事情都在表面上，即使它们并不美好。你在你的音乐中会利用这些吗，或者你是否以某种方式利用你所看到的？
One of the reasons, like specifically in my newest stuff, like one of the things that I'm really trying to tackle is just just a blunt conversation about certain things, right? Just having the blunt conversation and just saying, hey, this is how I see it. You know, and I think Birmingham kind of gives you that as a place. Specifically, like when you're getting into, like, venturing into country music, a lot of times people will say, oh, don't say that. Or, you know, they kind of treat it as if we don't talk like it. But it's like, no, no, when I'm from, we say what's on our minds. And like it, love it, hate it, it doesn't matter, right?
其中一个原因，特别是在我最新的作品中，我真正试图解决的事情之一就是关于某些事情的直白对话，对吧？只是进行直白的对话，只是说，嘿，我是这样看的。你知道，我认为伯明翰作为一个地方给了你这种能力。特别是，当你进入，比如，涉足乡村音乐时，很多时候人们会说，哦，别那么说。或者，你知道，他们对待它的方式就好像我们不是那样说话的。但事实是，不，不，我来自哪里，我们说出我们心里的想法。喜欢它，爱它，恨它，都没关系，对吧？
They want you to polish it or dress it up in a certain way? Or they want you to avoid the problem entirely and sing a happy song? Yeah, yeah. And I made room for happy music. One of the reasons that I'm doing this whole project is because I wanted to get back to happy me. And so most of this, I'm really a happy person. I don't know if you can tell, man, but like I'm a fun, happy person. And I spent so much time in L.A.
他们想让你润色它或者以某种方式包装它？还是他们想让你完全避开问题，唱一首快乐的歌？是的，是的。我为快乐的音乐留出了空间。我做整个项目的原因之一是因为我想回到快乐的我。所以大部分时间，我真的是一个快乐的人。我不知道你能不能看出来，伙计，但我是一个有趣、快乐的人。我在洛杉矶花了很多时间，
and L.A. had kind of like put a bunch of seriousness on me. And I just, I'm sick of that. So I wanted to make good fun, happy music. But at the same time, you know, it's an artist's job to reflect the times. And so, you know, I just have to be honest about all of that. Yeah. Well, and a lot of, a lot of the stuff that you've done, too, is kind of playing with Jonna, which I'd like to talk about because it's like, you know, you are a country artists.
而洛杉矶给我施加了很多严肃感。我只是，我厌倦了那个。所以我想要制作好的、有趣的、快乐的音乐。但与此同时，你知道，艺术家的工作是反映时代。所以，你知道，我必须对所有这些保持诚实。是的。好吧，而且你做过的很多事情，也是在玩弄类型，我想谈谈这个，因为就像，你知道，你是一位乡村艺术家。
And you see now more kind of like cross-pollination, I think, between rap and country and hip-hop and country, and even R&B in country sometimes now, like, than ever would have been around when I was in high school. Is there, like, kind of a way, but you're also not the traditional. country music singer just kind of like it's not the old kind of 70s country of like i lost my truck and my dog and my wife it's like not that new country where it's like i don't know a wheel used to make a joke did that like kind of like mid 2000s like iraq war pop country there was like you could use 15 words and the more you use them you got like a ding ding and you went up but if you use like another word it went down yeah yeah cherry toes in the sand in the truck and then you'd be
你现在看到更多种类的交叉，我认为，在说唱和乡村，嘻哈和乡村，甚至现在有时是R&B和乡村之间，比我在高中时可能出现的要多。有没有一种方式，但你也不是传统的乡村音乐歌手，就像它不是那种70年代的乡村，比如“我失去了我的卡车、我的狗和我的妻子”，它也不是那种新乡村，比如，我不知道，威廉曾经开过玩笑，那种2000年代中期的伊拉克战争流行乡村，就像你可以用15个词，你用得越多，你就得到一个叮叮声，你就上升了，但如果你用了另一个词，它就下降了，是的，是的，沙滩上的樱桃脚趾，在卡车里，然后你就会
like you know tax return uh-uh wrong wrong it was like you know you have this like 15 words It's like you're definitely not do anything like that. I mean, it's it's very like soulful songwriter, you know, almost kind of like indie rock stuff. I mean, tons of tons of influence there. I mean, can you say anything about you just kind of spit it out and then see what happens? Or do you think through that or? I think through it. I've got like some, I've got like some breaks in my mind.
像，你知道，退税，呃-呃，错了，错了，就像，你知道，你有这15个词。就像你绝对没有做任何类似的事情。我是说，它非常像灵魂乐创作，你知道，几乎有点像独立摇滚的东西。我是说，那里有大量的、大量的影响。我是说，你能说点什么吗，关于你只是把它吐出来，然后看看会发生什么？还是你会思考它，或者？我会思考它。我的脑子里有一些，我有一些休息时间。
I grew up in, I'm born at, you see my hair, 1980s. Yeah. But I was born 82, man. You know what I'm going. And so and my musical influences, I spent a lot of, lot of time in church my mom and dad were both preachers. When your mom was a preacher too, I knew your father was a preacher. Yeah, my mom and dad both preachers.
我成长于，我出生于，你看我的头发，1980年代。是的。但我出生于82年，伙计。你知道我要去哪儿。所以，我的音乐影响，我在教堂里花了很多时间，我妈妈和爸爸都是传教士。你妈妈也是传教士，我知道你父亲是传教士。是的，我妈妈和爸爸都是传教士。
Same church? Yeah. At the same time? Yeah. So I guess like you ever get in a fight like in the middle of the sermon, like, well, I got a great story about it. It wasn't my mom and dad. My dad and the co-fuster one time went outside and legit ran on fate.
同一个教堂？是的。同时？是的。所以我猜，你有没有在布道中间打过架，比如，好吧，我有一个关于它的很棒的故事。那不是我妈妈和爸爸。我爸爸和共同牧师有一次走到外面，合法地打了一架。
Like legit railway. Can't make him bloody than the whole night. Like real life. That's what I'm my oldest. Great. But, you know, I spent a lot of time at church. And my musical influences early on, because I got like uncles
就像合法的铁路。不能让他比整晚都血腥。就像现实生活。这就是我最老的。太棒了。但是，你知道，我在教堂花了很多时间。我早期的音乐影响，因为我有叔叔
that, like, you know, didn't spend as much time in church as me, uncles and cousins. But I got a little bit of hip-hop from that. And I went to Epic Elementary School. You're from Birmingham, anywhere. Yeah, yeah. Epic's like a melting pot, right?
他们，就像，你知道，没有像我一样在教堂花那么多时间，叔叔和表兄弟。但我从那里得到了一点嘻哈音乐。我去了Epic小学。你来自伯明翰，任何地方。是的，是的。Epic就像一个大熔炉，对吧？
So, you know, you know, it was very, like, integrated and, you know, that was just normal to me. So, like, the first hour, album I ever listened to that wasn't like a gospel album, was acting in Nirvana's unplugged. Oh, yeah. First thing I ever listened to that just wasn't a gospel, you know what I'm saying?
所以，你知道，你知道，它非常，就像，融合的，你知道，那对我来说很正常。所以，就像，我听过的第一张不是福音专辑的专辑，是Nirvana的《Unplugged》。哦，是的。我听过的第一张不是福音专辑的东西，你知道我在说什么吗？
And, you know, grew up a big Nirvana, you know, REM, Pearl Jam, like I was in that world. Right when MTV was starting to really, like, get a hold to what was happening. You know, so I grew up Tom Petty. I actually used Tom Petty and the Heartbreakers as like a, specifically last dance with Mary Jane. I used that song as a template for most. of the stuff I'm right.
而且，你知道，成长过程中是一个大的Nirvana，你知道，REM，Pearl Jam，就像我在那个世界里。就在MTV开始真正，就像，掌握正在发生的事情的时候。你知道，所以我成长过程中听Tom Petty。我实际上把Tom Petty and the Heartbreakers当作一个，特别是《Last Dance with Mary Jane》。我把那首歌当作我写的大部分东西的模板。
Right? Like that day, because he had to kind of like a little rapy, like, rhythm to, he grew up in an Indiana time. There is like a fast and a slow rhythm kind of pulling it in different directions. Yeah, just kind of pulling it.
对吧？就像那天，因为他有一种有点说唱的，节奏，他成长在一个印第安纳时代。有一种快和慢的节奏在不同的方向拉扯它。是的，只是有点拉扯。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And I used that as a template a lot in my music. That makes sense. Yeah. And then, you know, outside of that, once I started getting it, like, the next album I got that was just like not gospel was, oh, God.
是的，是的，是的。我在我的音乐中经常使用它作为模板。这说得通。是的。然后，你知道，在那之外，一旦我开始得到它，就像，我得到的下一张专辑只是像不是福音的，是，哦，天哪。
Sorry, about that. You're bad. Okay, I'm back. The next to my God, that wasn't gospel, was actually the Forest Gump soundtrack. I got that. I think in the sixth grade for Valentine's Day. And it was a two-disc, you know, what? Oh, my God, it was so great.
抱歉，关于那个。你很坏。好吧，我回来了。我得到的下一张不是福音的专辑，实际上是《阿甘正传》的原声带。我得到了那个。我想是在六年级情人节的时候。那是一张双碟，你知道吗？哦，天哪，它太棒了。
Oh, my God, it was so great. And, like, that's how I learned out about, like, Simon and Garfunkel and Creas Clearwater Revival. And so, like, I was getting, like, this old. Yeah, you could never license something like that outside of a movie. That would just be like millions of dollars. Millions of dollars, right? Really?
哦，天哪，它太棒了。而且，就像，那就是我如何了解，比如，Simon and Garfunkel和Creedence Clearwater Revival。所以，就像，我得到了，就像这个旧的。是的，你永远无法在电影之外授权这样的东西。那只会是数百万美元。数百万美元，对吧？真的吗？
It's like, but it was so great for me to like kind of like submerge myself in that for a while. I still had a lot of gospel. And then, you know, just over time I just kind of picked up different influences from different places. But I felt like all of it was this true story. What we call country music, hip hop music, jazz music, gospel music. at least those four, at least those four, all of them come from about 300 miles of each other. Hmm. Right. They are germane to the same people. Yeah. Right. The, the, you know, not, like a working class kind of fault. It's working, it's working. It's working. It's, you know, the core of that is, it's pop from, you know, 60 to 100 years ago, but it's a, it's a pop core of like this is what anyone could pick up and understand. Yes. Yes. And so it's working man's music and all of those different branches of music,
就像，但对我来说，沉浸在其中一段时间真是太棒了。我仍然有很多福音音乐。然后，你知道，随着时间的推移，我只是从不同的地方吸收了不同的影响。但我感觉所有这些都是这个真实的故事。我们称之为乡村音乐、嘻哈音乐、爵士音乐、福音音乐。至少那四个，至少那四个，它们都来自彼此约300英里之内。嗯。对。它们与同一个人有关。是的。对。那个，那个，你知道，不是，就像一个工人阶级的某种错误。它在工作，它在工作。它在工作。它，你知道，它的核心是，它是60到100年前的流行音乐，但它是一个流行核心，就像这是任何人都可以拿起并理解的东西。是的。是的。所以它是工人的音乐，所有这些不同的音乐分支，
they have this one thing in common to me. And it is that it is important to let the audience know that we're from the same place. Right. The first thing you ever find out about a hip hop star is where they are from, right? Where they are from is bigger than them, right? They might be the biggest thing where they're from. But they only matter because of where they're from, right? Yeah. Same thing is true in country music. Like, you might be the biggest thing out of Dallas, or you might be the biggest thing from Roanoke, Alabama. But you're never bigger than Roanoke.
它们对我来说有一个共同点。那就是让观众知道我们来自同一个地方很重要。对。你发现关于嘻哈明星的第一件事就是他们来自哪里，对吧？他们来自哪里比他们自己更重要，对吧？他们可能是他们来自的地方最大的东西。但他们之所以重要只是因为他们来自哪里，对吧？是的。乡村音乐也是如此。就像，你可能是达拉斯出来最大的东西，或者你可能是阿拉巴马州罗阿诺克出来最大的东西。但你永远不会比罗阿诺克大。
Right. Like, your old story is based than Roanoke. So I like to put those two things together, and I like to tell it, you know, this is where I'm from, and I'm not bigger than that program. I hope to be the biggest thing in the program, but I'm not bigger than the city. Well, that's beautiful.
对。就像，你的整个故事是基于罗阿诺克的。所以我喜欢把这两件事放在一起，我喜欢讲述它，你知道，这就是我来自哪里，我并不比那个项目大。我希望成为那个项目里最大的东西，但我并不比那个城市大。好吧，那太美了。
And do you, are there other artists that you like, not just in music, but that are kind of exploring that thing. Like, I don't know if you saw, I read a lot of kind of like independent comics and like, was it Southern Bastards. Actually, like, it ended up to be set in Birmingham. Nobody knew it was going to be, but then you see these scenes from Birmingham. But it was like, you know, there's these violent shots of people eating barbecue and like living in trailers.
而且你，还有其他你喜欢的艺术家吗，不仅是在音乐方面，而且是在探索那种东西的。就像，我不知道你有没有看到，我读了很多那种独立漫画，比如，是《Southern Bastards》吗？实际上，它最终设定在伯明翰。没人知道它会是，但后来你看到了这些来自伯明翰的场景。但就像，你知道，有这些人们吃烧烤和住在拖车里的暴力镜头。
And but it's, you know, it's a graphic novel. I've never said, I need to tick that. That one's really good. Yes. It's called Southern Bastards. That artist and author have done some cool stuff. and they'll go make the money doing like Marvel and Wolverine and then they'll come back and tell like a, you know, a little simple story. But yeah, you know, things like that kind of make me think of what you're doing because it's so familiar, but it's also a deconstruction of the familiar.
而且，你知道，这是一部图画小说。我从来没说过，我需要看看那个。那个真的很好。是的。它叫《Southern Bastards》。那个艺术家和作者做了一些很酷的事情。他们会去赚那些做漫威和金刚狼的钱，然后他们会回来讲述一个，你知道，一个小而简单的故事。但是是的，你知道，像那样的事情让我想到你在做什么，因为它太熟悉了，但它也是对熟悉的解构。
It's not just more of what you can go out and get at the record store or, you know, the, you know, decor store already. It's kind of a, I mean, like being a working class farmer guy with the style that you've got that is, you know, somewhat urban, somewhat laid back. You know, you know how to drive a tractor, but also your beard is pink. I mean, that's kind of a deconstruction of, you know, an idea. And like I think the, I hate to do this. This is so cheese, but it's true. When sinners came out last year, I thought to myself, oh, my God, that's the story. Right?
它不仅仅是你可以在唱片店或，你知道，装饰店已经能买到的东西。它是一种，我是说，作为一个有那种风格的工人阶级农民，那是，你知道，有点城市化，有点悠闲。你知道，你知道怎么开拖拉机，但你的胡子也是粉红色的。我是说，那是一种对，你知道，一个想法的解构。而且就像我认为，我讨厌这样做。这太俗气了，但这是真的。当《Sinners》去年出来的时候，我对自己说，哦，天哪，那就是故事。对吧？
Yeah. Like, that's the story. I kind of, I was deconstructed coming out of church. And being like this, I'm a preacher's son. I'm a church musician. that's where I learned to do all this stuff, right? But I felt this calling to go do it elsewhere, and I've had some success doing it elsewhere.
是的。就像，那就是故事。我有点，我从教堂出来时被解构了。并且像这样，我是传教士的儿子。我是教堂音乐家。那就是我学会做所有这些事情的地方，对吧？但我感到一种召唤去别处做这件事，并且我在别处取得了一些成功。
And I wanted to come back home and tell a lot of, literally, when I finally put out this whole album, this whole album is a deconstruction of what it means to be a black man in Alabama. Right? And the country parts of it, the more urban parts of it, the gospel parts of it,
我想回到家，讲述很多，字面上，当我最终发布整张专辑时，整张专辑是对作为一个阿拉巴马州的黑人意味着什么的解构。对吧？它的乡村部分，它更城市化的部分，它的福音部分，
the deconstruction of the gospel parts of it, the internal conflicts, the rises and falls, that's where the whole thing that's called sugar and salt. And that is a deconstruction of what it takes to make people addicted, right? Like, we're all born with this addiction to sugar and salt. It's all in what you do with it, right? So just getting it down to the bare knits and grits. I tell this story that, like, if you're from Birmingham or you're from Alabama, you know, there are sugar people that eat their grits with sugar and there are salt people, right?
对福音部分的解构，内部冲突，起起落落，这就是整个被称为《Sugar and Salt》的东西。而那是对让人上瘾需要什么的解构，对吧？就像，我们生来就对糖和盐上瘾。这完全取决于你用它做什么，对吧？所以只是把它弄到最基本的粗粮。我讲这个故事，就像，如果你来自伯明翰或者你来自阿拉巴马，你知道，有吃粗粮加糖的糖人，也有盐人，对吧？
They eat their gris with salt. And the sugar people think that the salt people are disgusting. And the salt people know that the sugar people have lost their minds, right? And which side is correct, though? You know, salt is right. I think the same for cornbread. I don't like sugar in the cornbread. Yeah, yeah.
他们吃加盐的粗粮。而糖人认为盐人很恶心。而盐人知道糖人已经失去了理智，对吧？但是哪一边是正确的呢？你知道，盐是对的。我想玉米面包也是一样。我不喜欢玉米面包里有糖。是的，是的。
Salt is grits. I'm supposed to be savory. And the mayor eats sugar in his grits. I couldn't even believe it. I can't even believe it, man. And I love that guy. You know what? You have my woodfin?
盐是粗粮。我应该是咸的。而市长在粗粮里吃糖。我甚至不敢相信。我甚至不敢相信，伙计。而且我爱那个家伙。你知道吗？你有我的Woodfin吗？
Woodfin's sugar in his griskin? sugar grit guy. Oh. Nice. So you see the animosity but when you strip it back, we're just two country grid eating sons of bitches, right?
Woodfin在粗粮里加糖？糖粗粮家伙。哦。不错。所以你看到了敌意，但当你把它剥开时，我们只是两个吃粗粮的乡下混蛋，对吧？
Right. And I want people to deconstruct that, like it's the grits that make it country. It's not how you talk it. Right. Like, that's the message I'm trying to get across. Like, oh, I'm from, I'm country,
对。我想让人们解构这一点，就像是粗粮让它变得乡村。不是你怎么说它。对。就像，那是我想传达的信息。就像，哦，我来自，我是乡村的，
right? Like, I don't want to have to explain that to you know better than that. You might top yours a little differently. You might talk about pickup trucks And I talk about Coup de Vills. But that's just what my granddaddy drove. Yeah.
对吧？就像，我不想不得不向你解释，你知道得比那更好。你可能会以不同的方式处理你的。你可能会谈论皮卡车，而我谈论凯迪拉克。但那只是我爷爷开的。是的。
Right? My granddad worked on steel plant. You know, my other grandma had a farm. You know, so I know that life too, but I grew up right on the line between Birmingham and Waltham. My grandma and Waltham had a farm. My grandma and tholemite was at the steel mill. You see what I'm saying? So.
对吧？我爷爷在钢铁厂工作。你知道，我另一个奶奶有一个农场。你知道，所以我知道那种生活，但我成长在伯明翰和Waltham之间的线上。我在Waltham的奶奶有一个农场。我在Tholemite的奶奶在钢铁厂。你明白我在说什么吗？所以。
Yeah. And that's a real life. That's not like, that's not some caricature I had to make up. That's really how I grew up, you know. So you've got both of those influences of kind of the culture. of the city and then also the culture of the country and a lot of the ideals of self-reliance and
是的。那是一个真实的生活。那不是像，那不是我必须编造的某种漫画。那真的是我成长的方式，你知道。所以你既有那种城市文化的，也有乡村文化的，以及很多关于自力更生和
community, you know, that sometimes you don't necessarily see in music as much as I mean, you're kind of, it's meeting people where they are, but also call them to action, which is hard to do at the same time. It's easy to kind of preach people. Yeah, what you're doing already is enough or, you know, rugged resilience,
社区的理想，你知道，有时你在音乐中看不到那么多，我是说，你有点，这是在人们所在的地方遇见他们，但也呼吁他们采取行动，这在同时做是很难的。很容易去说教人们。是的，你正在做的事情已经足够了，或者，你知道，坚韧不拔，
don't worry about it and, you know, end up on the Taylor Sheridan soundtrack or something. But, like, I don't know, maybe you're gone into that one. I want to burn any bridges for you. This is not reflected. No, you could, buddy. And one day when we're not doing this, let's just hang out, Roggan.
别担心，然后，你知道，最终出现在Taylor Sheridan的原声带上什么的。但是，我不知道，也许你已经进入了那个。我想为你烧掉任何桥梁。这没有反映。不，你可以，伙计。有一天当我们不做这个的时候，让我们只是出去玩，Roggan。
Yeah. God, I kind of see if I can remember it. This is way off topic for the podcast, but there was like, I made, we used to make, like, jokes about, like, if you were going to, we would make a song called, like, Taylor Sheridan and please hire me for your soundtrack, and it would be, like, a country song. But it would be like, it would just be, like, a parody of the kind of stuff that plays when the, like, Sunset rolls. I don't like someone tell you. I'm going to share it.
是的。天哪，我有点看看我能不能记住它。这离播客的主题太远了，但就像，我做了，我们过去常做，就像，关于，就像，如果你要，我们会做一首歌叫，就像，《Taylor Sheridan，请雇佣我做你的原声带》，它会是，就像，一首乡村歌曲。但它会是，就像，它只是，就像，当落日滚动时播放的那种东西的模仿。我不喜欢有人告诉你。我会分享它。
I'm fine. You know, money would be like. Yeah, like one of those songs was like, in my heart, there's a bar with seats for both of us, but now I'm drinking in my car because you went to Alcoholics Anonymous. And, you know, like that kind of like that kind of old banjo. Because I mean, the thing that I, because I grew up in Alabama and, you know,
我很好。你知道，钱会是。是的，就像那些歌之一是，在我的心里，有一个带座位的酒吧供我们俩坐，但现在我在我的车里喝酒，因为你去了匿名戒酒会。而且，你知道，就像那种，那种旧班卓琴。因为我是说，我，因为我在阿拉巴马长大，而且，你知道，
like if you asked me in high school, you know, like if I would ever listen to country music, have a cowboy hat, drive a truck, I would have been like, hell no, you know, like I'm protesting the Iraq war or whatever. And then, you know, two months ago I'm driving out to somewhere in Bessemer being like, this truck is $10,000 under Blue Book. I'm a social worker married to a teacher. I don't care if I got a scrape an American flag decal wrap with bullet holes in it off the back and a Confederate flag I'm getting used to struck.
就像如果你在高中时问我，你知道，就像我是否会听乡村音乐，戴牛仔帽，开卡车，我会说，见鬼不，你知道，就像我抗议伊拉克战争什么的。然后，你知道，两个月前我开车去Bessemer的某个地方，心想，这辆卡车比蓝皮书低10,000美元。我是一个嫁给老师的社会工作者。我不在乎我是否得刮掉一个带有弹孔的美国国旗贴纸，还有一个邦联旗，我正在习惯这辆卡车。
And I just, you know, like I love my cowboy hat. I love a lot of country music. But, you know, when I was at that time, like so much of that genre was I'm a guy who really wants to date somebody who doesn't want to date me and also I'm drunk and I think that's very deep. And that whole thing that's kind of disgusted me because that's not deep. Like you can do that and no shade, but like also don't tell that to me like, is this just so interesting and aren't I unique? Like, no, dog, not at all.
我只是，你知道，我喜欢我的牛仔帽。我喜欢很多乡村音乐。但是，你知道，当我在那个时候，就像那个类型的很多东西是，我是一个真的很想和不想和我约会的人约会的家伙，而且我也喝醉了，我认为那非常深刻。而整个事情让我感到恶心，因为那并不深刻。就像你可以那样做，没有阴影，但就像，也不要那样告诉我，就像，这难道不有趣吗，我难道不独特吗？就像，不，狗，一点也不。
Nah, you're not. You're not. And I think, I think a part of like a part of what I'm trying to build is like, bro, people from down here, like sometimes we get labeled that's dumb. or like shallow or you know whatever and it's like nah man like there's a there's a real politic to this place there's a real like um there are people down here who really love people there are people down here who really fight for things sometimes sometimes we don't get to be as amplified because you know we don't hold all the levels of power but man like
不，你不是。你不是。而且我认为，我认为我试图建立的一部分就像，兄弟，来自这里的人，就像有时我们被贴上愚蠢的标签。或者就像肤浅或者你，你知道，无论什么，就像，不，伙计，就像，这里有一个真正的政治。这里有一个真正的，嗯，这里的人们真的爱人，这里的人们真的为事情而战，有时，有时我们没有得到那么多的放大，因为你知道，我们没有掌握所有的权力水平，但伙计，就像
I don't know if you'll find better people on the planet man like it really is an interesting culture. And I think it's, but there's a politics to it. You're right. I mean, you kind of have to know how to interact in it.
我不知道你是否会在地球上找到更好的人，伙计，它确实是一种有趣的文化。而且我认为它是，但它有一种政治。你是对的。我是说，你有点必须知道如何在其中互动。
And I think from the outside, you lose that nuance. People just see something on the news or they look at, oh my lord, all of our political ads season. So I'm like watching these ads come in. And I don't know where they get the names for these people for one, but also like it's,
而且我认为从外面看，你失去了那种细微差别。人们只是在新闻上看到什么，或者他们看，哦，天哪，我们所有的政治广告季节。所以我就像看着这些广告进来。而且我不知道他们从哪里得到这些人的名字，首先，而且也就像，它
it's wild. There is a, there's like an ad that has been playing when I'm driving. And it's like for a gun store, but it's the same. that you should go to the gun store because the rapture's coming and you should like get some assault rifles for the rapture and it's like well if the rapture's coming what do I think the guns for I don't know who we should yeah do we need to revisit how the rapture thing is supposed to work like
它很狂野。有一个，有一个广告一直在播放，当我开车的时候。而且它就像一个枪店，但它是相同的。你应该去枪店，因为狂喜即将来临，你应该，就像，为狂喜买一些突击步枪，而且它就像，好吧，如果狂喜即将来临，我以为枪是干什么的？我不知道我们应该，是的，我们需要重新审视狂喜的事情应该如何运作吗？就像
you tell us about yeah you see what I'm saying like that and that's alabama when I first moved to l.A. there was like this I forget what mass shooting it was there been so many and that's so sad to say but when I first moved to L.A. there was a mass shooting and it might have been Sandy Hook as a matter of was saying to do it. And, you know, so of course they were talking about, you know, guns and gun violence. And I was like, oh, my God, y'all don't realize how easy it is to get a gun where I'm from. Yeah. And I was living in LA. So I came home to Birmingham and I did a little Instagram thing. I've taken it down since then because I've rebound my Instagram. But this is a little Instagram thing where I went to the place where you get the licenses. I wanted to get one legally. I wanted to show you how easy it was given. So I go to the place to get the gun down there by the courthouse.
你告诉我们关于，是的，你明白我在说什么吗？就像那个，那就是阿拉巴马。当我第一次搬到洛杉矶时，有，就像，这个，我忘了是哪次大规模枪击事件了，已经有太多了，而且说出来太悲伤了，但当我第一次搬到洛杉矶时，有一次大规模枪击事件，它可能是桑迪胡克，这是一个关于桑迪胡克的问题。而且，你知道，所以当然他们在谈论，你知道，枪支和枪支暴力。而且我当时心想，哦，天哪，你们没有意识到在我来自的地方得到一把枪有多容易。是的。而且我住在洛杉矶。所以我回到伯明翰，我做了一个小Instagram的事情。我从那以后把它删除了，因为我重新绑定了我的Instagram。但这是一个小Instagram的事情，我去了你获得许可证的地方。我想合法地获得一个。我想向你展示它有多容易。所以我去那个地方获得那里的枪，就在法院旁边。
I didn't know what it's called, but right down next to the courthouse. There was a sign in the parking lot that had a 15-minute parking limit, which means you had to be out of there in 15 minutes. I'd never seen, like, I was like, what? I went in, and it's a government building. Now, think about it. Government building. 15 minutes, you got to get it.
我不知道它叫什么，但就在法院旁边。停车场里有一个标志，限时15分钟，这意味着你必须在15分钟内离开那里。我从来没见过，就像，我当时心想，什么？我进去了，这是一个政府大楼。现在，想想看。政府大楼。15分钟，你得拿到它。
We will make it efficient. Got to get up. So I went in there. I got the permit. It's like $30, $40, whatever. Got the permit. Went down to Hoover Tactical. I should stay down now.
我们会让它高效。得起来。所以我进去了。我拿到了许可证。它就像30美元，40美元，无论多少。拿到了许可证。去了Hoover Tactical。我现在应该待在那里。
It was right behind my business, honestly. Okay. So you know what the collective, yeah. It used to be like a Winn-Dixie and it was a jail champ at one point. Yeah. There's a gun store. A little grocery store. Like, think about that.
它就在我的生意后面，老实说。好吧。所以你知道那个集体，是的。它过去就像一个Winn-Dixie，而且在某个时候是一个监狱冠军。是的。有一个枪店。一个小杂货店。就像，想想那个。
I go at the Huber Tactical. I stand in there and keep in mind, you know, they serve in all the people. And the lady finally comes to me and she says, what can I do for you? And I said, I need the biggest gun you got in here. That was it. I want the biggest gun you got in here. He said, well, I got this. But she hands me at AR-15 and they go, you need some bullets?
我去Huber Tactical。我站在那里，记住，你知道，他们服务所有的人。那位女士终于来到我面前，她说，我能为你做什么？我说，我需要你这里最大的枪。就是那样。我想要你这里最大的枪。他说，好吧，我有这个。但她递给我一把AR-15，他们说，你需要一些子弹吗？
I'm saying, let me get like a thousand. She says, okay, let me cash your credit. You need me high nitrogen and fertilizer? You need any enriched geranium? Yeah. I'm like, man, like what? Like, okay. But again, that's the politic, Alabama.
我说，让我拿一千发左右。她说，好的，让我刷你的信用卡。你需要我高氮和肥料吗？你需要任何浓缩锗吗？是的。我心想，伙计，就像什么？就像，好吧。但同样，那是政治，阿拉巴马。
You just have to kind of know that that's how it goes. and be responsible in that. You know what I'm saying? Like, you know, not abuse whatever that may be. It is something you can't fathom what that process is that way. I mean, not saying anything political like yes or no about it,
你只是必须有点知道事情就是这样。并且在那方面负责。你知道我在说什么吗？就像，你知道，不要滥用那可能是什么。这是你无法理解那个过程是那样的事情。我是说，不是说关于它的任何政治，就像是或否，
but like if you're from New York or, you know, like your shopping bag is regulated, you know, you could have that experience, you know, in the same country. In the same country. Yeah.
但就像如果你来自纽约，或者，你知道，就像你的购物袋是受管制的，你知道，你可以在同一个国家有那种经历。在同一个国家。是的。
Right. And I walked out of that, I walked out of that store, not even concealed because I had a license. Yeah. I walked out there. they're going to put it in a brown paper bag. Like you people just walking out like The Terminator.
对。而且我走出那家店，甚至没有隐蔽，因为我有许可证。是的。我走出那里。他们会把它放在一个棕色纸袋里。就像你们这些人只是像终结者一样走出来。
That's just walked out like Rambo. Yeah. But that's Alabama, man. And it's a beautiful place in that regard. But, you know, it's got it's someone has to tell that story and kind of, I hope to be one of the people who get to tell it. Well, when I read one of the things that I think is important to track like what we're losing in the psychotherapy profession and also like how it's changing and sort of
就像兰博一样走出来。是的。但那是阿拉巴马，伙计。而且在那方面它是一个美丽的地方。但是，你知道，它有，有人必须讲述那个故事，并且有点，我希望成为那些能讲述它的人之一。好吧，当我读到我认为追踪我们在心理治疗行业中正在失去的东西很重要的事情之一，以及它如何改变，并且某种程度上
becoming losing a lot of the depth that it had is I read the biographies of people you know from the founders and the people in the 70s going back to it and when I was doing that they all kind of described this feeling of like I kept thinking I was going to discover something and then when I got to the top I realized that I just was knowing what I had already known as a kid I'm in their own language and then when I started this podcast you talked to all these artists and not just musicians but like architects and fine artists painters all this stuff and a lot of them had encountered you know Jungian therapy or some kind of you know depth oriented therapy but not all of them and most of them are kind of saying the same thing. It seems like there's like two
变得失去了它曾经拥有的很多深度，我读了人们的传记，你知道，从创始人和70年代的人开始，回到它，当我这样做时，他们都描述了这种感觉，就像我一直以为我要发现什么，然后当我到达顶峰时，我意识到我只是知道我小时候已经知道的东西，我用他们自己的语言。然后当我开始这个播客时，你和所有这些艺术家交谈，不仅是音乐家，而且像建筑师和美术家、画家所有这些东西，他们中的很多人都遇到过，你知道，荣格治疗或某种，你知道，深度导向的治疗，但不是他们所有人。而且他们中的大多数人都在说同样的事情。看起来有，就像两个
primary things that are the most common. One of them is like I want to speak to myself when I was a kid. Like I want to be the artist that says something that I wish someone had told me when I was a kid. And then the other one is this idea of like I'm really trying to chew on my own psychology, understand it. I don't know what I'm trying to say. Like I'm making art because I want to come back and say it this way, say it another way, say it another way on the fifth record, on the fifth painting, go, oh, that's what those five things were saying. Sort of as an assignment. Any of those kind of relate to?
主要的事情是最常见的。其中之一就像，我想和我小时候的自己说话。就像我想成为那个说出我希望有人在我小时候告诉我的事情的艺术家。然后另一个是这种想法，就像我真的在试图咀嚼我自己的心理，理解它。我不知道我在试图说什么。就像我正在创作艺术，因为我想回来以这种方式说它，以另一种方式说它，在第五张唱片上，在第五幅画上再说一次，去，哦，那就是那五件事在说的。某种程度上作为一项任务。这些中的任何一个与你有关吗？
Are you just jumping off point for a reflection on your process? I speak a lot to my inner child for sure, right? Like, I say all the time that, like, eight-year-old me would love this guy, right? Would love this guy. And I don't even know if eight-year-old me would believe that this guy exists. where he would be, he would be my biggest fan. And so I do this for him. And I, well, that's a part of why I do it,
还是你只是对你的过程进行反思的跳板？我确实经常和我的内在小孩说话，对吧？就像，我一直说，就像，八岁的我会喜欢这个家伙，对吧？会喜欢这个家伙。而且我甚至不知道八岁的我是否会相信这个家伙存在。他在哪里，他会是我最大的粉丝。所以我为他做这个。而且我，好吧，那是为什么我做它的一部分，
but like, you know, to let him know that you're not as crazy as you think you are, you know, and you can be whatever you want to be. You can say it however you need to say it and blah, blah, blah. So a lot of it is that I tend to go into a studio. Sometimes I go in with like, like, something I really, really want to segment. Right. Like, I got a song that's doing pretty well. Now, Ice on the Road, I walked into the studio that day.
但就像，你知道，让他知道你并不像你想象的那么疯狂，你知道，你可以成为任何你想成为的人。你可以以任何你需要的方式说它，等等等等。所以很多是，我倾向于走进录音室。有时我带着，就像，就像，我真的，真的想分段的东西进去。对吧。就像，我有一首歌现在做得很好。现在在路上，我那天走进录音室。
With that on my mind, I want to tell you this. Yeah. And Ice on the Road is the one that's blown up. And that's the one, if you're listening to this, Google, we'll link to it in the show notes. But, I mean, every time I went back to kind of try and listen to the music to prepare for the enemy, then wrote two, three million more hits on that song. It was top of the pops. And I'm so thankful for that, man.
带着那个在我的脑海里。我想告诉你这个。是的。而《Ice on the Road》是那首爆炸的歌。而且那是那首，如果你正在听这个，谷歌，我们会在节目笔记中链接到它。但是，我是说，每次我回去试图听音乐为敌人做准备时，然后在那首歌上写了两、三百万次点击。它在流行榜榜首。而且我对此非常感激，伙计。
I'm really glad that people are listening to it. I think there's a huge market for anything other than every politician that we have right now. Like, I mean, the thing that I just kind of see across the board, because I mean, I see wildly different kinds of people. I don't really judge anybody. I think that if you're going to be a therapist, you got to love everybody. You don't necessarily have to, you maybe benefited from not liking them, but just loving them and holding them in the room. And, you know, I don't care what people's politics are. I don't care what their gender, sexuality, or anything.
我真的很高兴人们在听它。我认为除了我们现在拥有的每一位政治家之外，有一个巨大的市场。就像，我是说，我只是在各个方面看到的事情，因为我是说，我看到完全不同类型的人。我真的不评判任何人。我认为如果你要成为一名治疗师，你必须爱每个人。你不一定非要，你可能从不喜欢他们中受益，但只是爱他们并把他们留在房间里。而且，你知道，我不在乎人们的政治是什么。我不在乎他们的性别、性取向或任何东西。
I just like to get to know people and help you find you and usually take clean. a lot of things up along the way. But yeah, I mean, you're really saying that by the, and that's, by the time you get to, which sadly is not just relevant to bites probably, but by the time you get to the point where there's dead bodies in the street, something's wrong, you know, something's not working. And can we just back up and say, hey, it's sort of self-evident that this is not the way to do it. And then maybe figure out what's, I mean, if you can't get there, I mean, where can you? I'll at least be able to agree that that's not it, right?
我只是喜欢去了解人们，帮助你找到自我，通常在这一过程中清理掉很多东西。但确实，我的意思是，你真正想说的是，当你到达那个阶段——这恐怕不仅仅适用于“咬人”的情况，而是当你到达街上有尸体的地步时，说明出了问题，你知道，说明有些东西行不通了。我们能不能退一步说，嘿，这显然不是解决问题的方法。然后也许去找出原因，我的意思是，如果你连这一点都达不到，那你还能达到什么？至少我们能达成共识，认为那不是解决之道，对吧？
That seems like a very low bar is that piles of bodies is not an aspirational. That can't be it, man. And so sometimes you go in with that kind of thing. And then sometimes I go in really more or less to paint a feeling, right? Like I just want you to feel a certain thing, not necessarily to pay attention to my story. But, like, I want to give you hope or I want to give you happy feet, you know, give you something to hum along too. So, you know, but all of those things are really like speaking to, really I want to speak to the children, you know, we grow up, you know, and, yeah, we get old, whatever. But I don't know if we're supposed to grow up.
这似乎是一个非常低的门槛，尸横遍野并不是什么值得向往的目标。那不可能是终点，伙计。所以有时候你带着那种想法进去。而有时候我进去，更多是为了描绘一种感觉，对吧？就像我只是想让你感受到某种东西，而不一定非要关注我的故事。但是，我想给你希望，或者想让你感到快乐，你知道，给你一些可以跟着哼唱的东西。所以，你知道，所有这些其实都是在对话，我真的想和孩子们对话，你知道，我们长大了，你知道，是的，我们变老了，无论怎样。但我不知道我们是否真的应该长大。
I'm not sure of that, right? Not to the degree that we lose the young scientists that was in us all, right? You got to grow backwards and then it's more of a remembering unless. Yeah, man, like you got to remember like the curiosity. that you had as a kid and the, you know, the willingness to explore and, you know, get out of your safety zone. Because every day you were out of your safety zone, for one point, you were learning something new all the time. And then you get to a certain age and you feel like you know it all. And it's like, nah, nah, remember what it's like to keep learning every day.
我不确定这一点，对吧？不至于到我们失去了内心那个年轻科学家的程度，对吧？你得逆向成长，这更多是一种回忆，除非……是的，伙计，你得记住那种好奇心，那种你小时候拥有的好奇心，以及那种探索的意愿，你知道，走出你的舒适区。因为每一天你走出舒适区，在某种程度上，你都在不断学习新东西。然后当你到了某个年纪，你觉得自己什么都知道了。就像是，不，不，记住每天保持学习是什么感觉。
Remember what it's like to have new experiences and blah, blah, blah, blah. So, you know, that's kind of what I try to do in my music. Yeah. And are there other, I mean, there is a tradition. I mean, even in Birmingham of kind of, you know, like, alternative and, you know, especially like in the, and also people kind of making their, like, personality and aesthetic more of the mythology of the art, like people like SunRaw. And, you know, are there any kind of like African-American or, you know, musicians from the South that kind of, I'm going to stay here, but I'm also going to break the mold. And that's a little bit of the point, you know, I'm not just wrong. Man, SunRaw, you named one George Clinton, man.
记住拥有新体验是什么感觉，等等等等。所以，你知道，这就是我在音乐中尝试做的事情。是的。还有其他的吗，我的意思是，确实有一种传统。我的意思是，即使在伯明翰，也有那种，你知道，另类音乐的传统，你知道，特别是在……而且人们也倾向于将他们的个性和审美融入到艺术的神话中，比如像Sun Ra这样的人。而且，你知道，有没有那种非裔美国人，或者，你知道，来自南方的音乐人，那种“我要留在这里，但我也要打破常规”的人？这正是重点所在，你知道，我不只是错了。伙计，Sun Ra，你提到了乔治·克林顿，伙计。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. 3000. Yeah. Right. Hell, I think,
是的。是的。是的。3000。是的。对。见鬼，我想，
hey, like the, a part of being, like, a part of being down here is, a strut and peacock kind of thing. Like, like,
嘿，就像，作为……作为这里的一员，是一种昂首阔步、像孔雀一样的东西。就像，就像，
it's, you know, having an aesthetic, uh, that breaks mold is like a, uh, it takes a lot because I come from a working man's town, right?
这是，你知道，拥有一种打破常规的审美，这是一种……这需要很多勇气，因为我来自一个工人的城镇，对吧？
Like, this is still, you know? Which is it's an inherently, not even politically conservative, but it's conserving the normal. It's conserving the, let's put everybody in a blender and keep this lump average. And if you're saying something from the outside, that's really weird. You know, that's really, I'm a little bit afraid because I'm trying to kind of retain something. And, you know, that's so much the impulse when you're really breaking that and then forcing people to also have a connection with you.
就像，这仍然是，你知道？这本质上，甚至不是政治上的保守，而是对常态的保守。这是在保守那种“让我们把所有人都放进搅拌机里，保持这种平庸的团块”的状态。如果你在说一些来自外部的东西，那真的很奇怪。你知道，那真的让我有点害怕，因为我试图保留一些东西。而且，你知道，当你真正打破常规，并强迫人们也与你建立联系时，这种冲动是如此强烈。
And that's kind of the seed of change, you know. And it's not Christlike in a way. I mean, Jesus kind of was like, hey, I'm here, but I'm pointing you somewhere else. You know? Point some of us. Yeah. My dad is still, like, the preacher, but a steel worker, army man, right? Like, as conservative as you can think, right?
而这正是变革的种子，你知道。这在某种程度上并不像基督。我的意思是，耶稣有点像是，嘿，我在这里，但我指引你去别的地方。你知道？指引我们中的一些人。是的。我爸爸仍然是那种，传教士，但也是钢铁工人，军人，对吧？就像，你能想到的最保守的人，对吧？
Just conservative, evangelical army steelworker. Like, I don't even know if I can, if you get the picture, right? Yeah, yeah. That's a hard-in diagram to find the, find the middle of. Oh, that's literally, the Venn diagram is just a circle, bro. It's just one circle, bro. And that, he always wanted for me to be literally a productive member of society. That's what he wanted for me, right?
就是保守，福音派，军人，钢铁工人。就像，我甚至不知道我是否能，如果你能想象那个画面，对吧？是的，是的。那是一个很难找到中间点的维恩图。哦，那字面上，那个维恩图就是一个圆圈，兄弟。那只是一个圆圈，兄弟。而且，他一直希望我能真正成为社会中一个有生产力的成员。这就是他想要的，对吧？
First word I ever learned how to spell, this is not a joke. First word I ever learn how to spell is job. The first word ever learned how to spill. You know, he wanted me to be a preacher and, you know, maybe play some music for church and like just kind of following that tradition, get your steel job, blah, blah, and steel workers, they were the same navy blue, you know, dicky pants, you get what I'm saying?
我学会拼写的第一个词，这不是开玩笑。我学会拼写的第一个词是“工作”（job）。我学会拼写的第一个词。你知道，他希望我成为一名传教士，而且，你知道，也许在教堂弹弹音乐，就像那种遵循传统，找份钢铁厂的工作，等等，而钢铁工人们，他们都穿着同样的深蓝色，你知道，迪基裤（Dicky pants），你明白我的意思吗？
All of that. Yeah. Right. But that being said, that just didn't fit me well. You know, I think a lot about like the story of David and Goliath, when David went to go fight Goliath and, you know, they tried to put Saul's armor on him and it just didn't fit it.
所有这些。是的。对。但话虽如此，那并不适合我。你知道，我经常想到大卫和歌利亚的故事，当大卫去和歌利亚战斗时，你知道，他们试图把扫罗的盔甲穿在他身上，但根本不合身。
Right? He was like, I'm going to take a slingshot and go out here and do this, you know. And that's kind of how I see it. You know, like, it's not that I didn't want to, you know, be productive in society. I just, that just wasn't the outfit for me to do it. And that wasn't the way I saw making the world better. Yeah, when I worked like in Jasper, Alabama, sling blade and highways and stuff, in between college, it really was like everybody had the dicky overalls that the thrift store t-shirt or the plain white t-shirt and then the baseball hat that you wore every day.
对吧？他当时想，我要拿个弹弓出去做这件事，你知道。这就是我看待它的方式。你知道，并不是我不想，你知道，成为社会中有生产力的人。我只是，那套行头不适合我。那也不是我眼中让世界变得更好的方式。是的，当我在阿拉巴马州的贾斯珀工作时，割草、修路之类的，在大学期间，真的就像每个人都穿着迪基背带裤，或者旧货店的T恤，或者纯白T恤，然后戴着你每天都戴的棒球帽。
and that was like your uniformed for it. That was the other. But then, you know, that, that, like, being so heterogeneous, they had to have these kind of weird competitive personalities, like really lean into their, you know, like the cockfighted guy was always fighting, like, the, you know, souping up the truck guy. Yeah. Just weird, the weirdness of the community.
那就是你的制服。那是另一回事。但后来，你知道，那种，因为非常同质化，他们必须有这些奇怪的竞争性人格，比如真的倾向于他们的，你知道，比如斗鸡的人总是打架，比如，你知道，改装卡车的人。是的。只是奇怪，社区的怪异之处。
You got to be an individual in some way, right? Yeah. Yeah. Right. So, you know, but respecting the collective, you know, I honor those who came before me and all those still working people, you know, all those farming people, like I love them and they taught me a lot. But, you know, that just wasn't mold I was made for. Was that what he was working for Birmingham still?
你必须以某种方式成为一个个体，对吧？是的。是的。对。所以，你知道，但要尊重集体，你知道，我尊重那些在我之前的人，所有那些钢铁工人，你知道，所有那些务农的人，就像我爱他们，他们教会了我很多。但是，你知道，那并不是我被塑造出来的模子。那是他为伯明翰钢铁厂工作的时候吗？
Yep. Yeah. My dad worked for polymer cord code was right out there in Fairfield. And then, of course, he was in the Army and, you know, we went to church. As soon as he got out of work almost every day, so. So when you're taking that, you know, background to fit into, you know, the mythology of an artist, the persona of an artist,
是的。是的。我爸爸在费尔菲尔德外面的聚合物公司工作。然后，当然，他在军队里，而且，你知道，我们去教堂。他几乎每天一下班就去，所以。所以当你带着那种，你知道，背景去适应，你知道，艺术家的神话，艺术家的角色时，
which is, you know, some of you, but also, you know, you got to turn it up a little bit to have a thing, to have a performance. What are you taking? You know, start with, you know, why pink beard? Why a beard?
也就是，你知道，一部分是你，但同时，你知道，你得把它调高一点，才能有某种东西，才能有表演。你带了什么？你知道，从，你知道，为什么是粉色胡子？为什么是胡子？
Why pink? Okay, well, I had, I've been growing a beard for years. Fetcher is just kind of part of what I do. But I'm, I'm dyed at pink because, you know, I'm 44, so my beard is skunk under here,
为什么是粉色？好吧，我，我已经留胡子好几年了。胡子只是我所做的一部分。但我把它染成粉色是因为，你知道，我44岁了，所以我的胡子在这里是臭鼬色的，
right? It's black and white. And when I just, I spent a lot of time writing for other people. So I was just in the studio, I didn't really have, I didn't care about an aesthetic. I'm just,
对吧？它是黑白相间的。当我只是，我花了很多时间为别人写歌。所以我只是在录音室里，我真的没有，我不在乎审美。我只是，
old man coming in to write some songs, you know, I didn't really care. But when I got, when I decided I wanted to get back out and sing, I was like, man, I don't want to shave my beard. And I happened to meet these pastors. I was throwing a birthday party for a friend of mine in L.A., and her pastors had this color in their hair. I'm like, man, if I had hair, I'd dye my hair that color. And one of the brothers said it.
老头子进来写几首歌，你知道，我真的不在乎。但当我，当我决定我想重新出来唱歌时，我就想，伙计，我不想刮掉我的胡子。我碰巧遇到了这些牧师。我在洛杉矶为我的一个朋友举办生日派对，她的牧师头发上有这种颜色。我就想，伙计，如果我有头发，我会把头发染成那个颜色。其中一个兄弟说了。
Oh, you do it. It's just on your face. I was like, oh, I think that'd be interesting. I thought it'd be a good calling card. You don't really run into a whole lot of people with pink beards. So I figured it'd be a good calling card. And again, and it reminds me every morning that I need to do something to make this worth it. You know, because otherwise it just looks silly, you know.
哦，你去做吧。它只是在你的脸上。我就想，哦，我觉得那会很有趣。我觉得那会是一张很好的名片。你真的不会遇到很多人留着粉色胡子。所以我认为那会是一张很好的名片。而且，它每天早上提醒我，我需要做点什么让这一切变得值得。你知道，因为否则它看起来只是很傻，你知道。
Yeah. So it's like my, it was my push out of the nest. I was like, man, once you die your beard pink, you got to go. I mean, you've got to do something. So this like reminds me to get up and be productive and, you know, enjoy what I'm doing. Don't take it too serious. But just, it's got to be serious enough because otherwise you look silly. Yeah.
是的。所以这就像我的，这是我被推出巢穴。我就想，伙计，一旦你把胡子染成粉色，你就得出发了。我的意思是，你必须做点什么。所以这提醒我起床并保持高效，而且，你知道，享受我正在做的事情。不要太严肃。但它必须足够严肃，因为否则你看起来很傻。是的。
So, yeah. Yeah. That's a great line of trying to take yourself seriously, but not too seriously. So a lot of what makes it actually work. Like in any area, you think. So, you know, Alabama has some problems. We've touched on it. Your music goes into that.
所以，是的。是的。那是一句很棒的话，试图认真对待自己，但不要太认真。所以很多让它真正起作用的东西。就像在任何领域，你认为。所以，你知道，阿拉巴马州有一些问题。我们已经谈到了。你的音乐涉及到了这一点。
I mean, do you have, you have, like, kind of experiences where you, growing up, you saw, you know, this is wrong, or all of a sudden, oh, I realize my self-image was, you know, the culture was telling me it was bad, but actually it's good. having this kind of breakthrough or, you know, you know, if you have activist parents, I mean, sometimes you speak that language pretty early. But I mean, most of my career as a social worker, you know, in Alabama, but I was at the hospital or something. I'm a white guy in a polo shirt. So it's like a lot of people just feel comfortable telling you how racist they are sometimes, which I just, you couldn't, I always thought it was funny because like when I, when I first started
我的意思是，你有，你有，那种经历，当你，在成长过程中，你看到，你知道，这是错的，或者突然间，哦，我意识到我的自我形象是，你知道，文化告诉我它是坏的，但实际上它是好的。有这种突破，或者，你知道，你知道，如果你有激进的父母，我的意思是，有时候你很早就学会了那种语言。但我的意思是，我大部分职业生涯是作为社会工作者，你知道，在阿拉巴马州，但我是在医院什么的。我是一个穿着Polo衫的白人。所以就像很多人有时觉得告诉你他们有多种族主义很舒服，这让我，你不能，我一直觉得这很有趣，因为就像当我，当我刚开始
you'd go to these apartments and a lot of the people are, you know, on disability and kind of real hard up and you're trying to help them with a crack addiction or something. And sometimes you have to call the police for something if there's somebody, you know, if there's a break in or whatever. Like the police officers would always come in. And I think for the size of the city, Birmingham has a really, pretty good police force. I mean, there's some problems. But a ton of the time, you know, I'd be around the corner and they weren't expecting to see me.
你会去这些公寓，很多人是，你知道，靠残疾救济金生活，而且真的很困难，你试图帮助他们戒掉快克毒瘾什么的。有时如果有人，你知道，如果有人闯入什么的，你必须报警。就像警察总是会进来。而且我认为对于这个城市的规模来说，伯明翰有一支相当不错的警察部队。我的意思是，有一些问题。但很多时候，你知道，我会在拐角处，他们没料到会看到我。
And so they'd come into the apartment and like, well, well, we haven't. Oh, sir, we are, we had in a tactical kinetic, uh, report, uh, situation that we, Yeah, yeah. You're kind of like, that's the 180. I'm sorry. I, I, um, I would keep my, like, I went to elementary schools, very integrated. My middle school is very integrated. High school, pretty integrated, right?
所以他们会走进公寓，就像，好吧，好吧，我们没有。哦，先生，我们是，我们处于战术动力，呃，报告，呃，情况，我们……是的，是的。你有点像是，那是180度大转弯。对不起。我，我……我会保持我的，就像，我上小学，非常融合。我的初中非常融合。高中，相当融合，对吧？
Like, as far as that's concerned, I was around, I feel like good-hearted people. Yeah. But when I got to college, I was at, I wouldn't even say to school, but, you know, I was in undergrad. And I, I played in this band, so, like, kind of, sort of. Southern Rock, we did a lot of almond brothers kind of stuff, but, you know, just a cover band. We, you know, did that kind of stuff. And we were playing on the strip, and there's this young lady who took a liking to me.
就像，就这一点而言，我周围都是，我觉得心地善良的人。是的。但当我上大学时，我是在，我甚至不会说是学校，但，你知道，我是在读本科。而且我，我在这个乐队里演奏，所以，就像，某种程度上。南方摇滚，我们做了很多像奥尔曼兄弟乐队的东西，但是，你知道，只是一个翻唱乐队。我们，你知道，做了那种东西。我们在地带（the strip）演出，有个年轻女士看上了我。
But I was the front man. He's supposed to like the front man, you know? Right. And she happened to be white. And so during the set break, we were standing outside and she's talking to me, blah, blah. Another guy is kind of standing out to the side. He looks back at her and says, you're not supposed to talk to him. He's an N-word, right?
但我当时是主唱。他应该喜欢主唱，你知道？对。而且她碰巧是白人。所以在演出间隙，我们站在外面，她在跟我说话，等等。另一个人站在旁边。他回头看着她说，你不应该跟他说话。他是黑鬼（N-word），对吧？
And I looked back, and I looked at him as a police officer standing rid of it, like, maybe arms late the way. I look at the police officer, the police officer looks at me, and then he turns his head, right? And I said, sir, if I knocked him out, will you turn your head again? And he looked at me, he turned his head. And then I, you know, keep in mind, I'm a preacher's kid, man. So I thought about all the Sunday schools I've been to and, you know, you're supposed to turn the other cheek. And, you know, I get it.
我回头看，我看着他，一个警察站在旁边，就像，也许一臂之遥。我看着警察，警察看着我，然后他转过头去，对吧？我说，先生，如果我把他打倒，你会再转过头去吗？他看着我，他转过头去。然后我，你知道，记住，我是传教士的孩子，伙计。所以我想到我参加过的所有主日学，而且，你知道，你应该转过另一边脸。而且，你知道，我明白了。
And, you know, what would Jesus do? And then I knocked them out. Punched them right in this race. And I picked him up, brought him in the bar, set him on the stool, all these drinks the whole rest of the night. We actually became really good friends after that. And he stayed. He, like, he accepted it.
而且，你知道，耶稣会怎么做？然后我把他打倒了。一拳打在他脸上。我把他扶起来，带进酒吧，让他坐在凳子上，整晚都请他喝酒。在那之后我们实际上成了很好的朋友。而且他留下来了。他，就像，他接受了。
He did. He accepted. Okay. He accepted. And like to this day, we're actually pretty decent friends. That was a life-changing moment before us both, I believe. Wow. Um, and because, again, growing up, I never really had, like, you know what I'm saying?
他确实。他接受了。好吧。他接受了。而且直到今天，我们实际上还是相当不错的朋友。我相信那对我们俩来说都是一个改变人生的时刻。哇。嗯，而且因为，再次强调，在成长过程中，我从来没有真正有过，你知道我在说什么吗？
Like, I'm not saying it didn't exist. I just lived in a bubble that, like, that's just not how I live life, right? Yeah. I mean, Birmingham is pretty metropolitan. I mean, there's, like, there, I mean, there's some sundown towns in Alabama. There's some places you probably don't want to be hanging out too long. I don't know how much of that's changed, but there definitely was when I was in high school. Yeah. But, you know, that was my first time really, like, experience or something like that. But I knew, I knew then, like, that's not, that's not the way to live, man.
就像，我不是说它不存在。我只是生活在一个泡沫里，就像，那不是我生活的方式，对吧？是的。我的意思是，伯明翰相当大都市化。我的意思是，有，就像，我的意思是，阿拉巴马州有一些“日落镇”（sundown towns）。有些地方你可能不想待太久。我不知道那改变了多少，但在我上高中时肯定有。是的。但是，你知道，那是我第一次真正，就像，经历那样的事情。但我当时就知道，就像，那不是，那不是生活的方式，伙计。
Like, you know, judge a person on their content, bro. Judge them on their character. And, you know, I've been raised that way. And I feel like that's the way we all treat everybody, you know. So it's something that you were kind of in conversation with that you never controlled you, but you were always kind of aware of how to be managed. Yeah. And me
就像，你知道，根据一个人的内容来评判一个人，兄弟。根据他们的品格来评判他们。而且，你知道，我是那样长大的。我觉得那是我们对待每个人的方式，你知道。所以这是你一直在对话的东西，你从未控制过，但你总是知道如何被管理。是的。而我
probably I had to learn like early on I had counselors and stuff when I was a kid like my mom put me in therapy when I was super young
可能我必须很早就学会，我小时候有辅导员什么的，就像我妈妈在我很小的时候就把我送去接受治疗
because I did have a while like I keep talking about how my parents were preachers but my dad was a while like I mean not like a drug addict or anything like that really straight arrow kind of guy
因为我确实有一段时间，就像我一直在说我的父母是传教士，但我爸爸有一段时间，就像，我的意思是，不是像吸毒者什么的，真的是个很正直的人
but like mean right because he was so straight arrow and And, you know, my mom put me in counseling when I was really young. So he was, he was like the military mindset of that time of like, you got to be 100% perfect to make sure that you have every opportunity. Yes. You know, pure discipline. Like, like, that's just what my dad was and he was, you know, like just the.
但是，就像，刻薄，对吧？因为他太正直了，而且，你知道，我妈妈在我很小的时候就把我送去咨询。所以他，他就像那个时代那种军事心态，就像，你必须百分之百完美，以确保你拥有每一个机会。是的。你知道，纯粹的纪律。就像，就像，这就是我爸爸，而且他，你知道，就像只是那个。
True Detective Season 3 type. Yeah, like that kind of. Yes. You know, and so, you know, growing up, I really, I dealt a lot with, like, how to deal with, like, my own. issues, right? Because I wanted to fight back and I, you know, I wanted to, and I was bigger than other kids. So, and I was learning that if someone disagreed with you and you had the power to hurt them, you hurt them. Yeah, yeah.
《真探》第三季那种类型。是的，就像那种。是的。你知道，所以，你知道，在成长过程中，我真的处理了很多，就像，如何处理，就像，我自己的问题，对吧？因为我想反击，而且我，你知道，我想，而且我比其他孩子大。所以，而且我正在学习，如果有人不同意你的观点，而你有能力伤害他们，你就伤害他们。是的，是的。
Right. Um, so I, you know, I dealt with that a lot of the kids and, and fortunately, thanks to my mom and that there, bro, like I, that really helped me out a lot in life. And it, and then Dr. Paula Brown, I'll never forget the later mention rest of the soul. I've seen people who knew her, generally like older therapists have mentioned stuff like that. I mean, she was kind of an OG. A G and a, and a doll, man, like a just a sweet lady, man. And she, you know, she kind of put kind of like, hey, man, you know, do this thing. Express yourself in music.
对。嗯，所以，你知道，我处理了很多孩子的问题，而且幸运的是，多亏了我妈妈和那个，兄弟，就像，那真的在生活中帮了我很多。而且，然后是保拉·布朗博士，我永远不会忘记，愿她安息。我见过认识她的人，通常像年长的治疗师提到过类似的事情。我的意思是，她算是一个OG（元老）。一个G，而且是一个甜心，伙计，就像一个甜美的女士，伙计。而且她，你知道，她有点像是，嘿，伙计，你知道，做这件事。在音乐中表达你自己。
Like, you know, you could sing about it. I would sing a little songs when I came to therapy, you know. So a part of why I exist today is because of that. So I'm really appreciative to that. And it really did help me, like, process my feelings. And I still do that to this day. Well, I try and stay away from any of the, like, Mark Marion territory of, like, what would your dad like?
就像，你知道，你可以唱出来。我来治疗时会唱一些小歌，你知道。所以我今天存在的一部分是因为那个。所以我真的很感激。而且它确实帮助我，就像，处理我的感受。而且我直到今天还在这样做。好吧，我尽量远离任何像马克·马龙（Marc Maron）那种领地，比如你爸爸喜欢什么？
What do you talk about in therapy? But, you know, like, I don't know, for the lack of a better, you know, like, what, you know, do you see things from your childhood that you kind of engage with in therapy as an adult or as a kid or, you know, um, that you're not come off. Yeah, man. Um, maybe even to my dis, like, to my down. downfall to a certain degree, having that therapy young taught me how to talk through a conflict, right? Like, you know, make sure you understand what that person is saying to you and make sure that you are understood, right?
你在治疗中谈论什么？但是，你知道，就像，我不知道，因为缺乏更好的，你知道，就像，什么，你知道，你是否在童年时期看到你在成年后或小时候在治疗中参与的事情，或者，你知道，嗯，你没有表现出来。是的，伙计。嗯，甚至可能到我的，就像，到我的垮台在某种程度上，年轻时接受那种治疗教会了我如何通过冲突进行交谈，对吧？就像，你知道，确保你理解那个人在对你说什么，并确保你被理解，对吧？
Like, make sure you tell the truth because you can't fix what you won't say, what you won't reveal, man. And so I used that to this day. You can't hear what you won't reveal. And so, you know, even in my relationship now, and I'm sure she hates me, not should we like each other. But, like, I'm very much like, hey, my love, I want to make sure I'm understanding you. Let me repeat what I think I'm hearing you say. Am I getting that right? You know, and sometimes you just want me to get it.
就像，确保你说真话，因为你无法修复你不会说、不会揭示的东西，伙计。所以我直到今天还在使用它。你无法听到你不会揭示的东西。所以，你知道，即使在我现在的关系中，我肯定她恨我，不是我们互相喜欢。但是，就像，我非常像是，嘿，我的爱人，我想确保我理解你。让我重复一遍我认为我听到你说的话。我理解对了吗？你知道，有时你只是想让我明白。
And I'm like, before I say, I got it, then you make sure I get it. And I want you to understand me. You know, this is what I'm trying to say. This is where I went wrong there. This is what I thought I was doing right there. Right. But I learned that, you know, even as a kid, like, you know, don't be afraid. Because I would run from, I would either run from conflict or run to it.
而我像是，在我说我明白了之前，你确保我明白了。而且我想让你理解我。你知道，这就是我试图说的。这就是我在那里做错的地方。这就是我以为我在那里做对的地方。对。但我学会了，你知道，即使小时候，就像，你知道，不要害怕。因为我会逃避，我会要么逃避冲突，要么冲向它。
Right? Like I, there was no real like mediation for me. Nothing to like, I would either completely shut down or we're going to fight, you know. And so I'm really thankful that I had that those experiences to help me like, you know, be able to move through those. Yeah. So do you have anything that's, you have anything that's upcoming? Do you want to get more into kind of film or start to act? I mean, you have a personality where it probably be, you know, probably be pretty easy to make the jump into, you know, showing up as a character actor and an HBO thing or something. You know, crazy.
对吧？就像我，对我来说没有真正的调解。没有什么可以像，我会要么完全关闭，要么我们要打架，你知道。所以我真的很感激我有那些经历来帮助我，就像，你知道，能够度过那些。是的。所以你有什么即将到来的事情吗？你想更多地进入电影领域或开始表演吗？我的意思是，你有一个个性，可能，你知道，可能很容易跳槽到，你知道，作为角色演员出现在HBO剧集或其他什么东西中。你知道，疯狂。
Up then, like, in music now, it doesn't make the money it used to make. So now you have to think about, like, what else you're going to do? But, um, right now, I'm, I'm really focusing on, um, this. I'm, I'm appearing on America's Got Talent. Uh, at some point next month, you guys should see me on, on TV. And I'm really going to just try to push this. I feel like this to me, this particular part of my life, I feel like it's going to be one of my most impactful times.
那么，就像，在现在的音乐中，它赚不到以前赚的钱了。所以现在你必须考虑，就像，你还要做什么？但是，嗯，现在，我，我真的专注于，嗯，这个。我，我将出现在《美国达人秀》上。嗯，下个月的某个时候，你们应该会在电视上看到我。而且我真的只是想尝试推动这一点。我觉得这对我来说，我生命中的这一特定部分，我觉得这将是我最有影响力的时期之一。
But I do want to write a book. So you're trying to sketch out some stuff on that. Well, awesome. Congratulations. I look forward to it. And when you got the book, come back and promote it. I'd love to in the hometown. Yes, sir.
但我确实想写一本书。所以你正在尝试勾勒一些关于那方面的内容。好吧，太棒了。恭喜。我很期待。当你有了书，回来推广它。我很乐意在故乡。是的，先生。
I love talking about, I love talking to artists, especially when they're switching kind of mediums or exploring the same thing in a different medium. So that, like, when you, you know, maybe you do want to talk about that. Some people are kind of scared to just because of the forces in the industry, but it's like you used to be able to make money as a pop musician. Now you can have millions of views,
我喜欢谈论，我喜欢和艺术家交谈，特别是当他们转换媒介或在不同媒介中探索同一事物时。所以，就像，当你，你知道，也许你确实想谈论那个。有些人有点害怕，只是因为行业中的力量，但就像你以前能够作为流行音乐人赚钱。现在你可以有数百万的浏览量，
and Spotify and this kind of streaming economy crap has figured out how the, which those companies aren't making money anyway, which is kind of frustrating that people took money away from other people to have some new business model to lose the money for themselves. But love them. Yeah, but like, you know, so it's done this like weird thing to the industry where like now everything has to be events.
而Spotify和这种流媒体经济垃圾已经弄清楚了如何，这些公司反正也不赚钱，这有点令人沮丧，人们从其他人那里拿走钱，为了某种新的商业模式而为自己亏钱。但爱他们。是的，但是，就像，你知道，所以它对行业做了这种奇怪的事情，就像现在一切都必须是活动。
Like you have to be like an event size. artist and you have that means that you're dealing with one of five companies really two or three companies that own venues and have this kind of tort monopoly and all this stuff and then you have to like and then that also means that the concert can't just be a concert where you go up and do it and maybe a you know intermission you have to have sets and blazers and film production stuff in order because they're kind of trying to turn the the money is in the events you know so it's like all that's I've watched that slowly happen over 10 years. And it has the same effect that a lot of our culture does,
就像你必须是一个活动规模的艺术家，这意味着你正在处理五家公司中的一家，实际上是两三家拥有场馆并拥有这种侵权垄断和所有这些东西的公司，然后你必须，就像，然后这也意味着演唱会不能只是一个你上去做完就走的演唱会，也许一个，你知道，中场休息，你必须有布景和激光和电影制作的东西，因为他们有点试图把，钱在活动里，你知道，所以就像所有这些，我看着它在10年里慢慢发生。而且它和我们很多文化一样，有同样的效果，
where it makes a whole lot of losers and a couple winners. You know, these people make, you know, millions of dollars. And they're essentially going on, you know, 18 trailer trucks and their kids have a little house that gets rebuilt behind the stadium
它制造了一大堆失败者和几个赢家。你知道，这些人赚，你知道，数百万美元。而且他们基本上是在，你知道，18辆拖车卡车上，他们的孩子在体育场后面有一个被重建的小房子
every day so that they never feel like they're in a different thing. And in tons and tons of money. And like, that's great. You know, if you get to be inked, that's great. But like,
每天，这样他们就永远不会觉得自己在不同的地方。而且有大量的钱。而且，就像，那太棒了。你知道，如果你能成为那个，那太棒了。但是，就像，
you know, there's not the pathway to just kind of be a, middle class or upper middle class or slightly wealthy, you know, musician, even, even actor. You're starting to sit at that. You know, yeah, these industries as they change, I mean, you got any thoughts on that? Yeah. My thoughts, I've always, here's the socialism. I'm all power with all the people, man.
你知道，没有途径去仅仅成为一个，中产阶级或中上阶级或稍微富有，你知道，音乐人，甚至，甚至演员。你开始坐在那个位置。你知道，是的，这些行业随着它们的变化，我的意思是，你对此有什么想法吗？是的。我的想法，我一直，这就是社会主义。我与所有人同在，伙计。
And I mean that, you know, a dollar is only worth what you say is worth. And the consumer is the battery for all industry, right? And I say all that to say that whatever you want to see happen is what has to happen. Right. Like they can make whatever model they want to make. My goal has been specifically this year. Like I'm coming to see people where they are. You know, like I'm, and if that's, it's somebody's backyard, I'm pulling up on you. You know, and I'm bringing my band and you just tell your friends come over. Right. And that way, that way we can do that. You know, because the human can
我的意思是，你知道，一美元只值你说它值多少。消费者是所有行业的电池，对吧？我说了所有这些，是为了说，无论你想看到什么发生，那才是必须发生的。对。就像他们可以制造他们想制造的任何模型。我的目标是今年特别明确。就像我正来到人们所在的地方。你知道，就像我，如果那是，某人的后院，我正开车去找你。你知道，我带着我的乐队，你只要告诉你的朋友过来。对。那样，那样我们就能做到。你知道，因为人类的
connection, none of that. I mean, nothing against your laser shows, right? But I think that there's a heartbeat that goes on, especially as things start to kind of, I guess the world starts to kind of get weirder and weirder. I think people are looking for something that's a bit more human. Right? And as we get more AI and I'm not, you know,
联系，没什么针对你的激光表演，对吧？但我认为有一种心跳在继续，特别是在事情开始，我猜世界开始变得越来越奇怪的时候。我认为人们正在寻找一些更人性化的东西。对吧？而且随着我们得到更多的AI，而且我不是，你知道，
I'm not like the anti-AI person. I don't use it personally, but, you know, to each his own. But I think there's... How many are right now? I'm at the beach. This is a Jedi holocron.
我不是那种反AI的人。我个人不使用它，但是，你知道，各有所好。但我认为有……现在有多少？我在海滩上。这是一个绝地全息记录仪。
I just... Well, that's nice. I'm not really like. That's nice. It looks good. One day, though, you could be in that situation. You don't even know if the... But it's all, right?
我只是……好吧，那很好。我真的不是那种。那很好。看起来不错。有一天，虽然，你可能会处于那种情况。你甚至不知道是否……但这一切，对吧？
Like, and nothing against that, right? But I think people are going to be looking for, like, you know, just real heart-to-heart-to-heart-human-type interactions. And so I just, I want to be at least that. bridge while I can. I won't be by the time I leave Earth, they probably won't have a single human being singing in anything. So, especially Jim Z is like really
就像，没什么针对那个，对吧？但我认为人们会寻找，就像，你知道，只是真正的心对心的人类互动。所以我只是，我想至少成为那座桥梁，只要我能。在我离开地球时，他们可能不会有一个人类在任何东西里唱歌。所以，特别是Z世代就像真的
rebelling against AI. I mean, they're, they'll like, um, they won't, um, they're, they're real, uh, angry about that because they came about, you know, when this period where the internet was mostly crap and, you know, I think it's kind of like, a more extreme version of the millennials that had watched, you know, their, their parents like,
反抗AI。我的意思是，他们，他们会，嗯，他们，他们真的很，呃，对那个感到愤怒，因为他们出现，你知道，在这个互联网大部分是垃圾的时期，而且，你知道，我认为这有点像，千禧一代的更极端版本，他们看着，你知道，他们的，他们的父母就像，
get a best buy an applebee's and they're like, We want authentic, real culture. We're going to hang up Edison classic light bulbs on strings. Here will only be made in this one spot. And then, you know, that kind of gets co-opted or whatever. But, yeah, I think the Jim Z thing is like an even stronger reaction to the same thing. I'm hoping that the kids will be all right, man. Because we're going to need human beings, man.
去百思买和Applebee's，他们就像，我们想要真实、真正的文化。我们要把爱迪生经典灯泡挂在绳子上。这里将只在这个地方制造。然后，你知道，那种东西被挪用什么的。但是，是的，我认为Z世代的事情是对同一件事的更强烈的反应。我希望孩子们会没事的，伙计。因为我们需要人类，伙计。
We're not quite in post-humanistic world yet. And so we're going to need human beings and human beings to tell real stories and put real emotion behind it. And yeah, so that's really all I can hope for us to be a person who brings value to that. And, you know, if selling records is a way of the past, I can understand that. You know, business models change. And I think that right now what we're selling is we're selling characters. And so I just want to be a valuable character. Yeah.
我们还没有完全进入后人类世界。所以我们需要人类，需要人类来讲述真实的故事，并在背后投入真实的情感。是的，所以我能希望的只是成为一个为之带来价值的人。而且，你知道，如果卖唱片是过去的方式，我可以理解。你知道，商业模式会变。而且我认为现在我们卖的是，我们卖的是角色。所以我只是想成为一个有价值的角色。是的。
Yeah, it is. I mean, do you have anything to say about becoming a character? because it is this kind of involuntary process of when you become a pop musician, you're almost part of the collective mythology. I mean, people are thinking of you like Superman, Batman, Zeus, and not just, you know, there may be an understanding that you're a person too,
是的，它是。我的意思是，你对成为一个角色有什么要说的吗？因为它是一种当你成为流行音乐人时，你几乎是集体神话的一部分的非自愿过程。我的意思是，人们把你想象成超人、蝙蝠侠、宙斯，而不仅仅是，你知道，可能有一种理解，你也是一个人，
but you're representing a thing. And, you know, too, like, you know, so much of the history of the music that you're mining, there's, you know, African-American ballads about, you know, social justice and protection. And then, I mean, there's also, you know, not just white, but largely white, you know, songs about Blair Mountain and socialism and coal mining
但你代表了一件事。而且，你知道，也，就像，你知道，你正在挖掘的音乐历史的很大一部分，有，你知道，关于，你知道，社会正义和保护的非裔美国民谣。然后，我的意思是，也有，你知道，不仅仅是白人，而是很大程度上是白人，你知道，关于布莱尔山（Blair Mountain）和社会主义和煤矿开采的歌曲
and pushing back on the worst excesses of capitalism that go back 150 years in this area. I mean, I'll open end to turn that over to you. Yeah, you know, as far as being a character as concerned, as a songwriter, I used to tell, like, when the young artists would come see me, I would always ask them, you know, who things? Like, who are you and who wants to dress? like you, right? In other words, like a part of this is just a visual, like a visual thing.
以及推回资本主义最坏的过剩，这在这个地区可以追溯到150年前。我的意思是，我会开放地把它交给你。是的，你知道，就成为一个角色而言，作为词曲作者，我过去常说，就像，当年轻艺术家来看我时，我总是问他们，你知道，谁唱歌？就像，你是谁，谁想穿得像你，对吧？换句话说，就像这的一部分只是一个视觉，就像一个视觉的东西。
Like, not that everybody would want to do this, but you could dress as me for Halloween easily, right? And that's a, that was a big part of why I wanted to do this. I want you to be able to dress as me for Halloween to make a visual impact. You're like a poster with like a Vulcan with a pink beard? That'd be a, that'd be a cool. Yeah, right. I hadn't, but that's a good look. That's a good look. Thanks for the, thanks for the looking, but then as far as like the collective mythology, you're right. You know, punch of music specifically. Again, it's working man's folk music, right?
就像，不是每个人都想这样做，但你可以很容易地为万圣节打扮成我，对吧？而且那是一个，那是我为什么想做这个的很大一部分原因。我希望你能为了万圣节打扮成我，产生视觉冲击。你就像一张海报，上面有一个留着粉色胡子的瓦肯人？那会是一个，那会是一个很酷的。是的，对。我没有，但那是一个很好的造型。那是一个很好的造型。谢谢你的，谢谢你的关注，但至于集体神话，你是对的。你知道，朋克音乐特别。再次强调，它是工人的民谣，对吧？
And it tells this story of like just what it's like where you're from, the ups and downs. You know, in the South, we've always kind of had like this kind of anti-elitist mindset, right? You know, food on your neck type thing. And I think once it starts to lose that, you do the art of disservice. And I'm not saying everything has to be the blues, right?
而且它讲述了这个故事，就像你来自哪里，起起落落。你知道，在南方，我们一直有一种，就像这种反精英的心态，对吧？你知道，食物在你的脖子上那种东西。而且我认为一旦它开始失去那个，你就对艺术造成了伤害。我不是说一切都必须是蓝调，对吧？
But I'm saying that reality just, you have to have something that represents whatever reality may be. And so I think being a part of that and hearing these, like during this whole time I've been hearing all these songs, you know, that's showing that angst, I miss when white kids were in their dad's garage is making angsty music, right? Get back in the garage, Clayton, and play that guitar, right? Yeah, Parker, definitely needs to, you know, post-punk was going somewhere.
但我说的是现实只是，你必须有一些东西代表无论现实可能是什么。所以我认为成为其中的一部分并听到这些，就像在这段时间里我一直在听所有这些歌，你知道，那显示了那种焦虑，我想念白人孩子在他们爸爸的车库里制作焦虑音乐的时候，对吧？回到车库去，克莱顿，弹那把吉他，对吧？是的，帕克，绝对需要，你知道，后朋克正在去往某处。
Yes, man, get back in there and tell them how angry you are. You know what I need that, right? You were here Planet X Records, that's what was big when I was in high school, is like that kind of, like, anti-folk punk thing that had no melody to it at all. And, you know, it was like coming out of Texas and, like, Indiana, do that. Food, not bombs was, like, a big part of it. But it was like, yeah, there were so many cassette tapes in high school where it was like, they didn't have any musical ability. They're just like, you use the steeples of your churches to cover up the graveyard of your crimes.
是的，伙计，回到那里去告诉他们你有多愤怒。你知道我需要那个，对吧？你在这里Planet X Records，那是我上高中时很火的，就像那种，就像，反民谣朋克的东西，它根本没有任何旋律。而且，你知道，它来自德克萨斯和，就像，印第安纳，做那个。食物，而不是炸弹（Food Not Bombs）是，就像，它很大的一部分。但它就像，是的，高中里有那么多盒式磁带，就像，他们没有任何音乐能力。他们只是，就像，你用你教堂的尖顶来掩盖你罪行的墓地。
I smoked cigarettes in the graveyard. Screw you, dad. You know, that was the genre. Yes. Get that off your chest, man. You know what I'm saying? Like, get that off your chest. I love that.
我在墓地抽烟。去你的，爸爸。你知道，那就是那个流派。是的。把那个从你胸口拿出来，伙计。你知道我在说什么吗？就像，把那个从你胸口拿出来。我喜欢那个。
Um, and we need, like, you know, because we're, we're going to. we kind of got hyper-capitalistic. And now it's about making money, if I can get it online, blah, blah, blah. You know, the art itself stems from our successes and our failures. And I feel like I'm starting to hear that again more and more. Once people are out of hope, then they have to make their own hope. And it tends to come out in the art. Yeah.
嗯，我们需要，就像，你知道，因为我们，我们正在。我们有点变得超级资本主义了。现在它是关于赚钱，如果我能在线上得到它，等等。你知道，艺术本身源于我们的成功和我们的失败。而且我觉得我开始越来越多地再次听到那个。一旦人们失去了希望，那么他们就必须制造他们自己的希望。而且它倾向于在艺术中表现出来。是的。
Right. Like once the money stops working, once the chase for money stops working, people tend to just go back to that garage, man and yeah because they got nothing to lose or win yeah right um so as long as they still got garages you know you might be uh putting on a subscription for your garage next year but whatever um do you see the culture moving back to a time like that i mean i've said for a while i feel like we're kind of moving back to the 70s like the oil embargo this like people looking inward because there's not as much stuff outside to distract them you know like the ability to
对。就像一旦钱不再起作用，一旦对钱的追逐不再起作用，人们倾向于只是回到那个车库，伙计，而且是的，因为他们没有什么可失去或赢得的，是的，对。嗯，只要他们还有车库，你知道，你明年可能会为你的车库订阅，但无论如何，嗯，你看到文化回到那样的时间吗？我的意思是，我说了一段时间，我觉得我们有点回到70年代，就像石油禁运，这种人们向内看，因为外面没有那么多东西来分散他们的注意力，你知道，就像能力去
consume as much if there's a recession and less oil, you know, people look inward. Yeah, and cultured shifts when people have to do that. You see, you know, any parallels or, you know, oh, yeah, I can see that even starting in COVID. When COVID hit and people couldn't go outside, people got created. Boy, now, fair enough, we had the internet. Right. Well, man, like most of the stars that you see today were born in COVID. Right? Like, they figured out what to do with their phone. They figured out what to do with their camera.
消费那么多，如果经济衰退和石油减少，你知道，人们向内看。是的，而且当人们必须这样做时，文化会转变。你看到，你知道，任何相似之处，或者，你知道，哦，是的，我甚至可以看到它在新冠期间开始。当新冠来袭，人们不能出去时，人们变得有创造力。天哪，现在，公平地说，我们有互联网。对。好吧，伙计，就像你今天看到的很多明星都是在新冠期间出生的。对吧？就像，他们弄清楚了用他们的手机做什么。他们弄清楚了用他们的相机做什么。
They figured out what to do with their voice. They, like, when people are forced to sit with themselves, they have to sit with themselves, you know? I think a part of what you're starting to hear now in music, and even from the consumer to the artist is, you know, people just want something real, right? Like, people just want to hear something real. They want to hear something that relates to them,
他们弄清楚了用他们的声音做什么。他们，就像，当人们被迫与自己坐在一起时，他们必须与自己坐在一起，你知道？我认为你现在在音乐中开始听到的一部分，甚至从消费者到艺术家，是，你知道，人们只是想要真实的东西，对吧？就像，人们只是想听到真实的东西。他们想听到与他们相关的东西，
something that they can feel. And that's that's really my goal. I want to give people a whole range of emotions. Life is not always happy, but it's not always said. You know, I don't always have it all worked out, but I'm not always drunk, you know, you know. So I think people just, they want to be able to attach to something that's real. Yeah. I think in figuring out how to get back to it or what real means, you know,
一种他们能感受到的东西。这确实是我的目标。我想给人们带来一系列的情感。生活并不总是快乐的，但也不总是悲伤的。你知道，我并不总是把一切都处理得井井有条，但我也不总是喝得烂醉，你知道的。所以我认为人们只是想能够与真实的东西产生共鸣。是的。我认为在弄清楚如何回归本真，或者弄清楚“真实”意味着什么的过程中，你知道，
in the inevitably digital world is probably the future. And one touched by the algorithm in some ways, you know, you've got to touch the algorithm a little, bit to find the real. And I think that people are kind of figuring out in show business now, but it was like there was just really almost 10 year period where they just said, hey, we're not going to give you money anymore, but we'll give you views. So this is the number that's like a real thing. But we'll give you this fake number. Is that good enough? And you know, some of these kids are like, okay, yeah. And now people are being like, wait a minute. 50 million views and you can't give me $15. What's going on? Like, yeah, I need. I got to
在这个不可避免的数字世界里，这可能就是未来。在某种程度上，它受到算法的影响，你知道，你必须稍微触碰一下算法才能找到真实的东西。我认为人们现在在演艺圈里也开始明白了，但曾经有那么一段近10年的时间，他们只是说，嘿，我们不再给你钱了，但我们会给你流量。所以这是一个看起来很真实的数字。但我们给你的是这个虚假的数字。这样可以吗？你知道，有些孩子会说，好吧，行。而现在人们开始觉得，等一下。5000万的播放量，你却连15美元都给不了我？这是怎么回事？就像，是的，我需要。我得
eat, man. Yeah. I get, you know, so figuring out that economy, you know, know, it's been a wild one. Because it's like, you need to be on the internet, right? It's just the shift where you live. I live online, man. But then how do I break away from that? Because I got a real family. I got real friends that I really love and I really need to just spend time with them and,
吃饭啊，伙计。是的。我明白，你知道，所以弄清楚那种经济模式，你知道，这真是一段疯狂的经历。因为这就像，你必须在互联网上，对吧？这只是你生活方式的转变。我生活在网上，伙计。但之后我该如何从中抽离呢？因为我有真实的家庭。我有我真正爱、真正需要花时间陪伴的真实朋友，而且，
you know, drink coffee and have breakfast or whatever, you know. But it's like, man, I need, I need, he's looking at 10 this week because my peak numbers are done. And I'm like, bro, just figuring out that balance, you know. It's a delicate one, but, you know, just have to go with what you can. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I want to be respectful of your time and kind of wrap up so that, you know, I don't run over. But is there, what is like the best way for people to engage with you out there and especially, like, the best venue for them to get yourself where you get the biggest cut, you know, Van Camp versus Amazon or Spotify versus Apple?
你知道，喝杯咖啡，吃顿早餐之类的，你知道。但就像，伙计，我需要，我需要，他这周盯着10个人看，因为我的高峰数据已经结束了。我就想，兄弟，弄清楚那种平衡，你知道。这很微妙，但是，你知道，你只能尽力而为。是的。是的。好吧，我想尊重你的时间，结束谈话，这样我就不会超时了。但是，人们与你互动的最好方式是什么，特别是，他们能让你获得最大收益的最佳平台是什么，你知道，Bandcamp还是亚马逊，或者Spotify还是Apple？
You know, what should people do that want to kind of get into the paint beard verse? If you want to be a part of my world, come see me live, man. Come see me. Digitally, I don't really care about, I mean, I'm not supposed to say this. Stream the music, thank you. Come see me, man.
你知道，那些想进入“粉红胡子宇宙”（Pink Beard verse）的人应该怎么做？如果你想成为我世界的一部分，来现场看我，伙计。来看我吧。在数字平台上，我真的不在乎，我是说，我不该这么说。去流媒体听音乐吧，谢谢。来现场看我吧，伙计。
Pull up on me at the show. Come hang out with me so you know what it is. Get the feeling and see what it feels like. I'm not really a recording artist. I'm an artist that records, and that's a difference, right? Like, come see me, come hang out with me. I'll be back in Birmingham and June.
在演出时来找我。来和我一起玩，这样你就知道是怎么回事了。去感受一下，看看那是什么感觉。我并不是一个纯粹的录音艺人。我是一个会录音的艺人，这有区别，对吧？来现场看我，来和我一起玩。我六月份会回到伯明翰。
I'm doing, oh, God, I wish I had it. I don't even have my calendar, but I'll promote, I promise you. But no matter where you are, if you hear this and you hear it, I'm coming to town, come see me. We'll figure out a ticket. I'm not charged and absorbent prices for my tickets. I'm not a part of the Ticketmaster gang or the Live Nation gang. I'm just out here doing shows, right?
我正在做，哦，天哪，我真希望我有。我甚至没带我的日程表，但我保证我会宣传的。但无论你在哪里，如果你听到了这个，你听说我要去你的城市，就来看我吧。我们会想办法搞到票的。我不会为我的票收取高昂的价格。我不是Ticketmaster或Live Nation帮派的一员。我只是在外面做演出，对吧？
And pull up on me so you get to see all like my crowds literally from four-year-olds to 80-4-year-olds. Real life. And we're dancing and we're singing and we're all having our own good time together. And I don't even know that's really the best thing for me. Like it's better for me. I think it's better for the people. But, you know, streaming music on. Apple if you got a stream one because they pay or title if you got it is actually the best
来找我吧，这样你就能看到我的观众，从四岁到八十四岁都有。真实的生活。我们一起跳舞，一起唱歌，我们都在一起享受美好的时光。我甚至不知道这对我来说是不是最好的。我觉得这对人们更好。但是，你知道，在Apple上流媒体播放音乐，如果你有流媒体的话，因为他们会付费，或者如果你有Tidal的话，其实是
paying of them all title if you do that um but again I want I want to put people together you know I want people to see that they've got neighbors that don't look like them or dress like them or live in that neighborhood per se but you all got this guy in common right and and I think the best way to do that is just to see that person like come see it so you can see this lesbian couple from Asheville North Carolina right and this old old-ass man from Montgomery, Alabama, right? That should never know each other, but they should know each other, you know what I'm saying?
他们之中支付报酬最高的，Tidal，如果你用那个的话。但再说一次，我想把人们聚在一起，你知道，我想让人们看到，他们有邻居，虽然长得不像他们，穿得不像他们，或者不一定住在那个社区，但你们都有这个共同点，对吧？而且我认为最好的方式就是去见那个人，去看看，这样你就能看到这对来自北卡罗来纳州阿什维尔的女同性恋情侣，还有这个来自阿拉巴马州蒙哥马利的超级老头，对吧？他们本不该认识，但他们应该认识，你知道我在说什么吗？
That's the magic, man. That part is so magical to me, man. The concert is part of the art form. The community is part of the art form. That's part of the persona. I'm going to tell you one thing. I'm going to share about this. Frankie Beverly died about two, three years ago.
这就是魔力，伙计。那部分对我来说太神奇了，伙计。演唱会是艺术形式的一部分。社区是艺术形式的一部分。那是人格的一部分。我要告诉你一件事。我要分享一下这个。Frankie Beverly大约两三年前去世了。
And I remember when Frankie Beverly died from, you know, Franklin Beverly Mays. And I've been seeing Frankie Beverly since I was a kid. I probably seen Frankie like eight, ten times in my life. Never even on purpose either. Because Frankie was a lot, you know, making music way before I was born. But he was always at like music festivals and stuff. And he was old when I was a kid, right?
我记得Frankie Beverly去世的时候，你知道，Franklin Beverly Mays。我从还是个孩子的时候就开始看Frankie Beverly了。我这辈子大概看过Frankie八到十次。甚至都不是故意的。因为Frankie在我出生前很久就开始做音乐了。但他总是出现在音乐节之类的活动上。而且我小时候他就是个老人了，对吧？
And so he would come out and go, you made me happy. And point that mic, he didn't have to sing another word for the rest of the show. Right. And I realized that Frankie Beverly was the highest paid microphone stand in the world. Right. We didn't go to Frankie Beverly concerts. to hear Frankie Beverly sing to us, we went to Frankie Beverly
所以他会出来说，你让我快乐。然后把麦克风指向观众，演出剩下的时间他甚至不需要再唱一个字。对吧。我意识到Frankie Beverly是世界上薪水最高的麦克风架。对吧。我们去Frankie Beverly的演唱会不是为了听Frankie Beverly给我们唱歌，我们去是为了
could watch us sing to him. And that kind of community is the kind I'm trying to build. Right? Like, this is not about pink beard. I just happen to be the button that brings the two sides of the shirt together. You know what I'm saying?
看我们为他唱歌。那种社区感就是我试图建立的那种。对吧？这与“粉红胡子”无关。我只是碰巧成为了把衬衫两边扣在一起的那个扣子。你知道我在说什么吗？
But I want to be, that kind of energy is, like, you could touch it. Like, that's real to me. And that's what I'm trying to build in these shows. Yeah, I'd love to bring both my kids to see you. I got a five-year-old that is a huge dancer.
但我想要的是，那种能量是，你可以触碰到的。对我来说那是真实的。这就是我试图在这些演出中建立的东西。是的，我很乐意带我的两个孩子去看你。我有一个五岁的孩子，是个超级舞者。
and then my eight-year-old is she just loves energy so that'd be a ton of fun you got anything coming up byron city Saturn anything big i'll be a work play on oh god i don't i can't get to my call though i will just email me and i'll put it in the show notes and then if you're ever coming back to the south even if it's like you know in 10 months a year from now just you know me i'll put it out on the instagram and i'll relink to the episode clip the episode so you can only send me stuff enough We'll do. I'll send a team an email. As soon as I get off, I go, I'll check the calendar. Yeah, no rush, no rush at all. But yeah, anything you want to close with or kind of promote, I don't, I appreciate you so much coming on, you know, a show and, uh, you know, have a conversation. Man, thank you. On the way out now, I just want to, again, thank you for having me, man. It's always a privilege to be able to chat with people, for somebody to think that I'm
然后我八岁的女儿，她就是喜欢那种能量，所以那会非常有趣。你最近有什么安排吗，伯明翰的Saturn，有什么大事吗？我会去WorkPlay，哦天哪，我没法看我的日程表，但我会发邮件给你，我会把它放在节目说明里。如果你以后再回南方，即使是10个月或一年后，只要你知道我，我会把它发在Instagram上，我会重新链接到这一集，这样你就可以只发给我东西。好的，没问题。我一挂断电话就会给团队发邮件，我会查看日程表。好的，不急，一点也不急。但是，有什么你想结束或宣传的吗？我非常感谢你来参加节目，进行了一次对话。伙计，谢谢你。在离开之前，我只想再次感谢你邀请我，伙计。能够与人交谈，有人认为我
interesting enough to sit down with, you know, and so. Oh, no, you're like my ideal guest. I was really happy that I was, get past the agent, even if I can get in front of the artists, they're kind of, they're interested, but sometimes those agents are like, if you're not,
足够有趣而坐下来交谈，这总是一种荣幸，你知道，所以。哦，不，你是我理想的嘉宾。我真的很高兴我能越过经纪人，即使我能直接面对艺人，他们也挺感兴趣的，但有时那些经纪人会说，如果你没有，
you know, five million. Oh, man, no, not. I appreciate the time. I appreciate the time. I appreciate it. And if there's anything I want to promote,
你知道，五百万粉丝。哦，伙计，不，不是那样的。我很感激这段时间。我很感激这段时间。我很感激。如果有什么我想宣传的，
you know, make sure, come and see me on Instagram, pink beer, P-Y-N-K-B-E-A-R-D or Twitter. I mean, X, I'm sorry, the same thing or,
你知道，一定要在Instagram上来看我，Pink Beard，P-Y-N-K-B-E-A-R-D，或者Twitter。我是说，X，抱歉，是一样的，或者，
any way you find me, P-Y-N-K-B-E-R-D, all one word. Follow me there and, and, you know, join the community and, you know, let's pitch in and do the best that we can to make this world better, you know, one song at a time, one handshake at a time, one smile at the time. Yeah, that's awesome. You want to close with a, you got a barbecue recipe you like, you want to close with a rib recipe or something. I'm curious to swap tips because I've been working on my rib recipe for like 20 years.
任何你找到我的方式，P-Y-N-K-B-E-R-D，连在一起。在那里关注我，加入这个社区，让我们尽我们所能让这个世界变得更好，你知道，一次一首歌，一次握手，一次微笑。是的，那太棒了。你想用一个烧烤食谱来结束吗？你有什么喜欢的肋排食谱之类的吗？我很好奇，想交流一下技巧，因为我研究我的肋排食谱已经20年了。
Let me put you up on a secret to baked potatoes. Okay. Okay. Hear me out here. No foil. Mm-hmm. Okay. Fort three holes and three stabs in the potato. Both sides were six and all. Brine it.
让我告诉你一个烤土豆的秘诀。好的。好的。听我说。不要用锡纸。嗯哼。好的。在土豆上戳三个洞，戳三下。两面都要，总共六下。盐水浸泡。
Three seconds. That's it. Three seconds. Put it in the oven. 375, 400 for 45 minutes. Take it out. Olive oil. Back in the oven.
三秒钟。就是这样。三秒钟。放进烤箱。375到400度烤45分钟。拿出来。涂上橄榄油。放回烤箱。
4.50. 15. You're going to get a good crisp, you know, chew on your skins inside, mashed potatoes. Massed. I mean, no clumps, no nothing, just. That sounds perfect. It is the perfect baked potato.
450度烤15分钟。你会得到一种很好的酥脆感，你知道，咀嚼你的皮，里面是土豆泥。捣碎的。我是说，没有结块，什么都没有，只是。听起来很完美。这就是完美的烤土豆。
And I share with people out there, it is the perfect baked potato. I'm going to try that out. That makes sense. I always do tons of salt, but the brine probably makes a little bit more sense to get it in there. Brian, right.
我分享给外面的人，这就是完美的烤土豆。我要试试看。这很有道理。我总是放大量的盐，但盐水浸泡可能更有道理，能让盐分进去。盐水，对吧。
Because the total I get it, but sometimes you don't want to eat it because it's too salty on outside. Yeah. Little brine. That's going to kind of crisp it up on that outside when you put that oil on in the flesh, kind of flash fried a bit. I mean,
因为我明白总盐量，但有时你不想吃它，因为它外面太咸了。是的。一点盐水。当你涂上油时，它会在外面变得酥脆，在果肉上，有点像快炸了一样。我是说，
three seconds the brine will penetrate into the potato? Get into the potato. It sounds weird because you think, well, they didn't do anything. Three seconds. Just make sure you get it in there a little bit. Perfect baked potato. That's fascinating. Every time.
三秒钟，盐水能渗透进土豆里吗？进入土豆。听起来很奇怪，因为你会想，好吧，它们什么都没做。三秒钟。只要确保它进去一点点就行。完美的烤土豆。这太迷人了。每次都是。
I'll check that out for sure. Yeah. Well, thank you so much for coming on. I really appreciate you. I picked up my phone. It's all congressman. A lot of money in his pocket, little blood on his hands. If they gunned me down, I bet no one can't.
我一定会去试试的。好的。非常感谢你来参加。我拿起我的手机。全是国会议员。口袋里有很多钱，手上沾着一点血。如果他们枪杀了我，我敢打赌没人能。
A lot of babies in the ground saying thoughts and rats. Too many babies in the ground with the thoughts of friends. But keep quiet and tell me in secret. Where are your neighbors? When did you last see you? Is anything great? Can't have you met Jesus? What was it teaching?
地上有很多婴儿在说“思念与祈祷”。地上有太多的婴儿伴随着朋友的思念。但保持安静，私下告诉我。你的邻居在哪里？你最后一次见到他们是什么时候？有什么伟大的事情吗？你见过耶稣吗？他在教什么？
Did you believe him? Be quiet. Tell me in secrets. Where are those strangers? And when did you feed them? Is anything great? Can't have you met Jesus. I think we might need him.
你相信他吗？安静点。私下告诉我。那些陌生人在哪里？你什么时候喂过他们？有什么伟大的事情吗？你见过耶稣吗？我想我们可能需要他。
But would you believe him? Would you believe him? Cover your eyes play blind why they pose and smile over someone's chimes You can't clean this up through a talk with God I can't burn this down with revival fires Oh no Only light gonna fix this dark world of eyes Hey hey keep quiet
但你会相信他吗？你会相信他吗？蒙上你的眼睛，假装看不见，当他们摆姿势微笑时，在某人的钟声之上，你无法通过与上帝的谈话来清理这一切，我无法用复兴之火烧毁这一切，哦不，只有光才能修复这个黑暗的世界，嘿嘿，保持安静
Tell me in secret Where are your neighbors And when did last see Is anything great yet? Have you met Jesus? And what was he teaching? Did you believe? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
私下告诉我，你的邻居在哪里？你最后一次见到他们是什么时候？有什么伟大的事情吗？你见过耶稣吗？他在教什么？你相信吗？这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。